Herbst 2013. Kalte Temperaturen, Regen und Gewitter lassen die Stimmung in ganz Deutschland sinken. In ganz Deutschland? Oh nein! Eine kleine Feiergemeinde bewahrt sich den Frohsinn.
Jugenderinnerung, ja du kennst das doch so. Damals, Sommer, die anderen kleinen Mädchen, die fanden auch alle nackt über den Strand, und du hattest dein Eis in der Hand und die Sonne schien. Alles war toll und ihr wart glücklich.
Und was war jetzt in der Story? Ist jetzt das Clickwird?
Na ja, mir geht es so ein bisschen mit dem iPod 5. Generation. Einfach der Traum von Audio-Steuerung.
Du hörst so ein bisschen die Bacardi-Musik im Hintergrund, oder was? Ich versuche gerade, das Bild, was du da...
Verstehe, das heißt der VFX-Spezialist, der dann ihr zugeteilt war, hat dann jedes Bild einzeln, der hatte dann auch zwei schwarze Typen hinter sich stehen.
Also zwei schwarz gekleidete Typen.
Ich habe bei Harry Potter die Stereoskopumwandlung mitgemacht, einfach mal so, weil ich wissen wollte, wie es jetzt so, aber wirklich als Artist so.
Stereoskopumwandlung. Ah, genau, das ist nämlich der Punkt. Ich habe doch irgendwann schon mal gesagt, dass die meisten Filme, die 3D sind, die werden ja nachträglich 3D, ne? Genau.
Also bei jedem 3D-Film ist ein großer Teil nachträglich gemacht. Es gibt keinen, der 100% 3D ist, auch die Hobbits nicht.
Wie meinst du das, er ist nicht 3D-feuer?
Er wird nicht mit zwei Kameras gefilmt, nicht alles mit zwei Kameras gefilmt.
Das heißt, die trennen die Layer auf und verschieben die dann so ein bisschen, ja?
Also ich kann ja mal sagen, was ich gehört habe, ich glaube bei Alice im Wunderland.
Der war komplett nachgemacht, der war gut gar nicht in 3D.
Genau, und es sind aber auch ganz viele, die das halt so machen. Da machen sie das halt mit Licht und Schatten, dass sie da das irgendwie aus dem Schatten sozusagen raus die Tiefinformationen versuchen noch nachträglich rauszudoktern.
Jaja, also Stereoskop-Conversion ist, wenn man die Kohlenmine der VFX-Business so, weil es gibt halt wirklich nur Rotoskoper, also es geht halt 90% darum, Sachen auszuschneiden. Dann muss man natürlich, wenn man die Sachen ausschneidet, dahinter auch wieder Informationen herstellen, die nicht da ist, also wenn ich jetzt so eine Person ausschneide und dann kann ich auch immer von rechts und von links hinter sie gucken, ist natürlich Informationen, die nicht da ist, die muss wieder reingemalt werden. Und dann ist natürlich so, das flach auszuschneiden und nach vorne zu holen, hast du dann halt so ausgeschnittene Pappfiguren dort. Und die muss halt auch wieder, da ich drei Dimensionen kriegen, sprich du baust dann auch noch 3D-Objekte, alles Handarbeit, komplett, 100% Handarbeit.
Aber warum filmen sie es denn nicht gleich, ein 3D?
Weil das nicht einfacher ist.
Das ist doch totaler Wahnsinn, ah!
Also natürlich ja, es ist ein bisschen einfacher und es wird auch immer einfacher.
Bei manchen Filmen ist die Idee halt erst später gekommen, weil Alice in Wonderland wurde gedreht, da war der 3D-Hype grade noch nicht so hoch. Und dann haben sich nachträglich die Boss entschieden, oh ja, wir wollen den aber in 3D haben, macht man, sonst wären wir den gar nicht los.
Genau, es ist am Set viel, viel aufwendiger. Du hast halt dieses 3D-Rig, das sind halt zwei Kameras. Eines gerade nach vorne, so wie man das kennt, und eines von oben drauf. Dann hast du dazwischen einen Halbspiegel, also einen Spiegel, der die Hälfte nach oben macht und die Hälfte durchmacht. Durch den Halbspiegel verlierst du ganz viel Licht. Das ist Nummer eins. Das heißt, du musst dein komplettes Licht-Setup verdoppeln.
Warte, warte, warum sind die Kameras nicht so nebeneinander, so auf Augenhöhe?
Weil diese fetten Kameras nicht so dicht aneinander treffen.
Durch das Objektiv. Die Objektive sind zu groß. Also die Rats gehen auch mittlerweile nebeneinander, aber die Objektive sind halt noch nach wie vor zu groß. Also gerade auch die großen, guten Objektive, die sind halt...
Das heißt, wenn man die so machen würde, dann wäre das nicht auf unserer Augenabstand und dann stimmt es irgendwie nicht.
Das kann man aber nicht wieder rausrechnen. Das kann man dann auch nicht irgendwie...
Das kannst du nicht wieder rausrechnen. Wie gesagt, das ist immer, was du dahinter siehst, ist nicht da. Also du musst das immer wieder nachträglich machen. Das heißt halt diesen Hohlspiegel. Dann ist das natürlich eine mechanische Einheit. Eine mechanische Einheit heißt halt, die ist nie 100 Prozent. Und wenn du da die Kamera leicht gedreht hast, weil irgendjemand gegengekommen ist oder sonst was, ist alles offen. Du fängst an zu schielen. Dann ist bei dem Hohlspiegel noch ein anderes Ding. Du verlierst die Reflektion auf der einen Seite. Das ist halt wie in so einem Polfilter. Das heißt, alle Reflektionen im Wasser oder in den Spiegeln ist an einer Seite nicht vorhanden. Die heißt, du musst wieder reinbauen. In die andere Seite.
Und wie gesagt, doppelt beleuchten auch noch mal.
Und dann noch mal doppelt so viel Licht auffahren.
Das heißt, die 3D-Filme sind nicht nur so dunkel, weil du die scheiß Brille auf der Nase hast, sondern auch noch, weil es vorne durch den Spiegellicht verloren gegangen ist. Warum machen wir denn Scheiß noch mal?
Das ist ja dann alles Betrug.
Tim, jetzt hast du die ganze Schokolade alleine aufgegessen.
Wir haben noch ein paar mehr hier. Da gibt es noch ein Keyboard.
Wer hat ihm irgendwas weggemacht, damit er nicht...
Wir müssen mal kurz einen kleinen Break machen hier. Ich dussele, habe irgendwie beim Aufräumen, glaube ich, jetzt...
Boah, eine Tastatur als Schokolade.
Hier gibt es nicht nur das, hier gibt es sogar auch ein iPhone als Schokolade.
Ein iPad als Schokolade.
Mir ist die Tastatur abgebrochen. Ich esse jetzt das R.
Es ist ja auch jetzt langsam Weihnachten. Also die wohlige Zeit beginnt. Das merkt man jetzt hier schon an den Schokoladengaben.
Croshen.
Finde ich.
Wie war das?
Kann ich auch ein Bitcoin bezahlen?
Ich seh den Satoshi.
Du bist ja auch so ein digitaler Minen-Arbeiter. Nein, ich nicht.
Ich bin Minenbesitzer.
Ja, genau, das ist der Unterschied. Vielleicht solltest du auch mal da einsteigen, aber die Minenbesitzer, Falk, geht's ja auch nicht gerade besonders gut. Dann hab ich so den Eindruck. Ich meine, die gehen ja immer alle pleite. Wenn wir jetzt halt den am Ende drauf, wie die Künstler kriegen nix.
Ja, es sind schon immer die Künstler, die arschten. Weil die sind natürlich auch alles Nerds. Die haben halt alle keine Anwälte. Die haben halt auch nicht den Drive, da auf die Straße zu gehen, großartig sich zu verbinden. Es gab halt so ein paar, gerade hier in Berlin im Pixelmono, da standen sie kurz vor dem Walkout. Sie standen kurz davor, auf die Straße zu gehen oder nicht mehr zur Arbeit zu kommen. Dann wurden sie auch bezahlt. Aber es gibt halt viele, die ich jahrelang auf der Weile gehe.
Also ich kenne auch einen Kumpel, der bei so einer Filmfirma arbeitet. Die machen nur 2D, Laura Stern und so ein Zeug.
Ich hoffe, ich kriege jetzt keinen Ärger.
Und was ich da für Stories höre, das ist unglaublich, was da an Geld fließt und dass es keinen kümmert und Fördergelder und so. Also da hört sich das alles ein bisschen anders an, wie bei dir.
Das ist sowieso ein ziemlich fieser Sklavenladen, diese ganze Filmbanche. Ich habe einen Ex-Kollegen in Ameland, den schmeißen wir regelmäßig zum Jahresende raus und stellen ihn nächstes Jahr wieder an. Weil, den jetzt mal die paar Tage über Weihnachten zu bezahlen, das geht nicht.
Das ist ja in der Filmbanche eh so. Ein Sommer für so eine Fernsehserie, dann irgendwie zwei, drei, vier Monate lang, gibt es auch richtig Geld. Und dafür dann aber sechs Monate, sieben Monate, gibt es gar nichts.
Wartest du aufs nächste.
Und dann musst du in der Zwischenzeit hier halt was anderes suchen oder mit deinem Geld irgendwie sparsam umgehen.
Und wenn sie oller geht oller. Also ich rede jetzt hier nicht über irgendwie Gurkenhausen Pictures, Acme, Inc. Sondern ich rede hier über Industrial Light & Magic. Die sind weit vorne dieser Sklavenhalter nochmal mit.
Aber ILM geht es halt auch nicht. Ja, also es geht halt keinem wirklich gut. Ich wollte gerade nochmal drauf zurückkommen. Den Einzelnen, denen es wirklich scheinbar am besten geht, ist halt VETA. Die haben halt viel richtig gemacht.
Wer?
VETA.
VETA?
Die so neuseländische Bode, die haben halt hier Herderringe.
Die machen alles. Also die machen Herderringe, die machen Avatar.
Wie Peter Jackson ist das und so.
Genau, das ist eine Firma von Peter Jackson. Also der hat die mit gegründet.
Wie schreibt man das? VETA.
W-E-T-A. Die haben auch noch einen Model-Shop und so mittlerweile. Also wo sie halt richtig Modell zu bauen, die man anfassen kann.
VETA, F-X-C-O-N-Z.
Die sind auch die Einzelnen, die nenntenswerte Research and Development. Also die Großen haben auch alle ein paar Leute Research and Development.
Und die haben auch ihre eigenen Tools dann entwickelt irgendwann, oder?
Genau, und die haben einen super guten Ansatz. Die haben halt auch wirklich Professoren da, die sich halt auch auskennen.
Ja gut, aber bei denen ist auch echt scheiße viel Geld geflossen durch die Herderringe-Geschichte, oder? Also ich meine, die können sich das halt leisten.
Aber auch da schlafen die Artists unter dem Tisch.
Ja, Research and Development ist das, was mein Ex-Kollege da auch macht. Den schicken sie dann los, sagen, wir machen jetzt hier wieder so ein Fantasy-Ding. Du recherchierst jetzt hier mal, wie es sich so nordische Helden sagen, wie die Häuser aussehen und was die für Schwerter hatten und bla und so. Da ist viel Arbeit.
Beim VFX geht es dann darum, wie sieht das Wasser aus oder wie sieht... keine Ahnung, die Feder aus, die da an der Eule sitzt oder so was. Wie verhält die sich im Wind und wie kann man das animieren, wie kann man das in Code umsetzen und wie kann man den Code in Maya integrieren. Darum geht es eigentlich immer.
Und die Pixar-Jungs, zählen die da auch mit rein?
Pixar ist eine eigene Nummer. Pixar ist toll, wir haben einen kleinen Fernsehfilm gemacht vor zwei Jahren, das war vor Cloud Atlas, mit sprechenden Tieren. Da wollten sie natürlich auch Hollywood-Qualität haben, die wir natürlich für ein hundertstel des Preises von so anderen Schweinchen, Babes etc. nicht bieten konnten. Aber es war ein sehr schönes Projekt, es gab 320 Shots, in einem Wahnsinn von vier Monaten umgesetzt mit einem sprechenden Schwein und einem sprechenden Hund. Mir hat es total Spaß gemacht, bei einem Output kann man lässt sich streiten, für die Umstände fand ich es sehr gelungen. Ist das öffentlich?
Wo ist der Link?
So richtig klassischer deutscher...
Shots heißt dann einzelne Szenen, oder wie?
Genau.
Nicht Anzahl der Bilder, sondern...
Einzelne Szenen.
5,9 auf eMDB, ne?
Ja, die sagt deutscher Fernsehfilm, ne? Also es ist einfach ein deutscher Fernsehfilm, ähm... mit nicht... Wir haben in der deutschen Story so Liebesgeschichte, blas, kinderkompatibel. Eigentlich war er nicht schlecht, ja? Es war nicht der Beste, aber es war halt so ein klassisches Ding, aber es war sehr, sehr schön, weil wir wirklich auch mal Haare machen konnten, und so weiter und so fort. Und dort habe ich halt eine komplette Rendernament-Pipeline aufgestellt von Null. Also ich habe die Pipeline komplett dafür wirklich gebaut, die habe ich auch selber programmiert, weil da war keiner da.
Kinder würdest du nie rendern, ne? Tiere, Schweine, alle da, aber keine Kinder.
Und da haben wir dann mal so ein paar 30-Lizenzen Rendermännern irgendwie gekauft, und geliest auch von Pixar. Und die kamen dann auch tatsächlich und haben... Mit der Post? Nee, nee, da kam dann auch so ein Team von Pixar, der uns besuchen. Und die fanden das total toll, dass wir das machen, weil wir dann eigentlich einen der größten, also sehr größten Customer in Deutschland auf einmal waren. Und das war wirklich klein. Es gibt wirklich nur eine super kleine Community. Es gibt dann nicht viel. Es gibt vielleicht, ich würde sagen, 6.000, 7.000 Artist weltweit, die sich intensiv im High-Level-Bereich mit VFX beschäftigen. Also das ist alles nicht so sehr groß.
Die kamen dann einfach mal vorbei, gegen Bezahlung einfach nur um zu gucken?
Genau.
Das waren noch Headhunter Versteckte, oder?
Ja, auch.
Und?
Ich habe mit denen eine World-Show gemacht. Das ist super cool. Ich habe auch viel mit denen noch, viel Kontakt. Ich bin aber nicht da. Amerika. Und vor allen Dingen bin ich halt auch kein, also ich bin halt nicht so der 3D, die suchten halt wirklich so 3D-Artisten. Es gibt nicht so viele, die wirklich sich mit 3D-Namen auskennen. Ich hatte immer gehofft, dass unser kleiner Junior-3D-Typ irgendwie da unterkommt. Aber das hat sich dann so ein bisschen verlaufen. Ja, war denn auch noch mal da und wollte, glaube ich, auch nicht so richtig. Weil das ist schon so eine Maschinerie, in der man dann ist.
Gratulation, Gerard, macht da Schweinchen-Gemöde.
Kann sein, dass die Tierchen dann nur mit 12 FPS gemacht wurden?
Ja, ist natürlich. Also wir haben bei Weitem wirklich ein Hundertstel des Budgets gehabt, was man so für heiligt.
Ich meine, das kommt ja immer noch hinzu, jetzt diese perfekte Render an den Dreh-Tracing-Trailer. Das ist ja eine Sache, aber ich glaube, das ist ja so ein Punkt, weswegen Pixar auch berühmt geworden ist. Gerade eben John Lasseter oder so, weil der es mal geschafft hat, Dinge mal schön zu animieren. Ich erinnere noch an den Klassiker mit den Lampen. Der hat es halt geschafft, dass eine Schreibtischlampe, ohne dass man ihr die Sicht drauf malt, traurig guckt. Allein durch die Bewegung. Und ich glaube, das ist das, was damals auch Pixar so ein bisschen den Durchbruch gebracht hat, weil tolle Bilder erinnern oder so. Klar, da haben die schon ihre Spezialisten, aber das konnten auch andere. Aber Dinge zu animieren, denen Leben einzuhauen, und nicht, dass jeder gleich sieht.
Ich habe hier letztens diesen Merida geguckt, oder? Oder Brave heißt der auf Englisch? Und das Mädel hat mehr Mimik als eine deutsche Schauspielerin. Ich habe letzten Sonntag Tatort geguckt, seit langer wieder. Und das ging gar nicht. Also wirklich, da war ein Schauspieler dabei, da denkste der auch, boh.
Also hier, mein Liebling.
Das kann nicht sein.
Mein Lieblingsdeutscher Film ist ja immer noch das Boot.
Da gibt es auch noch irgendeinen, der da nicht bekannt ist von. Sind ja wirklich alle durchgestartet, oder?
Und die waren damals auch schon total unverbraucht. Und das war einfach, also den Film gucke ich. Ja, der Drama-Geruchte. Ist halt so ein Winterfilm. Den guckt man nicht irgendwie, wenn man gerade draußen Sommer ist und gute Laune, aber.
Der war dabei. Grünemeyer.
Alle.
Raimund Harmsdorf.
Semmelroger.
Otto Sanders. Der Thunder-Typ hier auch.
All-Stars.
Ja, wirklich. Komplett.
Dann hier Semmelroger natürlich.
Ja, aber den ist auch schlimm geendet, oder?
Wieso? Gibt's immer noch so ein Stehaufmännchen. Knast und nicht knast und knast und nicht knast.
Jürgen Prochnow, Herbert Grönemeyer, Klaus Wennemann, Martin Semmelroger, ja, Heinz Hönig, Uwe Ochsenknecht, Claude Oliver Rudolf, als er noch aus der Wien...
Das ist der mit dem Namen, mit dem Pop-Namen?
Ralf Richter, ja, also wirklich Jan Fedder, da ist wirklich einmal alles Otto Sander, genau.
Ja, wir schauen mal wieder das Boot, finde ich jetzt. Guter Hinweis.
Ja, doch, der ist wirklich...
Mal jetzt für den Winter.
So, das ist der einzige... Ich habe nicht das Leben der anderen gesehen, aber so der einzige deutsche Film, finde ich, mich nicht so international schämen würde.
Befreundeter Regisseur unserer Familie, der Lothar Warnicke, jetzt verstorben, einer der bekanntesten ostdeutschen Regisseure, hat mal gesagt, zu diesem Problem dieser deutschen Schauspieler, dass der Unterschied zwischen einem deutschen Schauspieler und einem amerikanischen Schauspieler ist, dass der deutsche Schauspieler nur mit sich selbst spielt und der amerikanische Schauspieler mit seinem Team, auch wenn es nur ein Extra ist, der da irgendwie rumspringt, nimmt er das wahr. Und wenn man sich darauf hinsetzt, sind die deutschen Schauspieler sehr egozentrisch. Die sind nicht in der Szene, sie sind auch nicht mit den anderen Leuten zusammen.
Also es gibt ein paar, die gut sind, aber gerade auf dem Fernsehen ist wirklich schlechtes Zeug dabei.
Guck dir mal an, nur eine Serie, nimm so was wie Dexter, nimm so was wie Breaking Bad, irgendeine amerikanische Serie, jede Nebenrolle sind Profis, kommt mir so vor im Vergleich.
Ist jetzt ein bisschen fies vielleicht und ich gucke auch gerne deutsche Filme.
Aber die Spannenden sind amerikanische Dinger, die haben ja offensichtlich, ist ja ein riesen Land, aber die haben keine eigenen Schauspieler. Alles, was dort irgendwie spannend ist, kommt entweder aus Australien oder aus England oder aus Neuseeland, wenn es hochkommt.
Oder aus Österreich.
Wen denn noch? Ja, und der andere?
Na Dings. Na Oberst, Oberst.
Na Oberst, Oberst.
Ach so, ja.
Der ewige Nazi. Ich spiele ja immer so die Deutsch-Typen.
Na ja, aber ich habe mir jetzt hier von Tarantino, der letzte, wie heißt er noch, Kleine Dingo Unchained angeschaut. Also, der Typ ist einfach, Christoph Waltz glaube ich, der wird nochmal richtig fliegen irgendwie. Also, ich meine, der ist jetzt schon sehr bekannt, aber der Typ ist für Höheres geboren.
Das ist einfach großartig. An meinem Landsitz habe ich einen Nachbarn, der ist Schauspieler, er macht so Fernsehquack, wenn er was kriegt und so was. Der leidet natürlich auch wahnsinnig mit den Dialogen. Ich lache ihn jedes Mal aus. Ich habe eigentlich keinen Fernseher. Man guckt sich dann so die Sachen an, wo ich weiß, dass er mitspielt. Ich glaube, das sind die Bücher.
Das sind nicht die Schauspieler.
Das sind aber auch die Schauspieler.
Ja, das ist das ganze System. Aber da gehören diese Bücher auch dazu. Das ist alles so leblos und trocken und staubig. Lass uns nicht über die deutsche Filmindustrie reden.
Genau, haben wir den Falk jetzt genug eingedüngt?
Nein, nein, nein, da geht noch was.
Ich würde noch einmal ganz kurz hier, weil im Chat kurz steht, Mari ganz kurz eingehen, weil das ist nochmal eine ganz eigene 3D-Untersoftware-Kategorie, die in den letzten Jahren auch sehr groß geworden ist. Du baust ein Modell und dann gibt es diesen Render und dazwischen musst du aber in diesem Modell auch noch irgendwie Texturen geben und da gibt es eine ganze Menge Entwicklung, wie man das am besten macht, vor allem Programme, wo man direkt auf die Objekte malen kann und Mari ist zum Beispiel eins dieser Programme. Da gibt es auch noch Matbox von Autodesk, was das halt auch macht und auch das ZBrush kann das auch, mit ZBrush kann man dann auch sogar selber modellieren, mit Matbox auch so ein bisschen. Mit Mari kann man tatsächlich nur auf diese Objekte malen. Mari ist auch ein Development von VETA.
Du sagst immer, ihr macht jetzt alles selbst, ich hätte jetzt erwartet, dass es da irgendwie so Firmen gibt, die Pops herstellen, dass ich da einfach anrufen kann als Firma und dann sagen, hast du mal irgendwie eine Kaffeetasse im Standard-File-Format XY oder so und dann sagt der ja klar, hier 10 Dollar oder Lizenz für einen Film oder tralalala oder so. Gibt es sowas?
In der Werbung wurde es gemacht. TurboSquid ist da so die Seite, die man da haben will. Genau, und da gibt es halt so 3D Models in aller Couleur zu kaufen, die man irgendwie so kaufen kann. Auch im Marketplace.
Was heißt denn hier kaufen? Ich kaufe das benutze ich beliebig oft oder wird lizenziert oder?
Ja genau, du kaufst das und hast es dann und kannst es beliebig oft benutzen. Also ich weiß nicht, ob es mittlerweile verschiedene Lizenzmodelle gibt, weil ich glaube, letztes Mal, als ich geguckt habe, war das einfach kaufen.
Man kann die neue Nationalgalerie in Berlin kaufen, mit Kunst drin für 149 Dollar.
Das ist auch günstig, das ist auch fair. Natürlich sind die Modelle von der Qualität sehr unterschiedlich. Es geht ja wirklich darum, wie diese Polygonen gesetzt sind und so. Wenn man jetzt bestimmte Animationen haben will, meistens baut man es dann am Ende selbst. Aber gerade für Werbung, wo die Produktionszeiten extrem kurz sind, also wo man nicht die sechs Monate hat, irgendwie was zu entwickeln, sondern wo man jetzt sagt, nächste Woche muss da sein, was richtig geil aussieht, da trifft man sehr oft auf diese TurboSquid Modelle zurück.
Gibt es ein Standard-File-Format für das alles, das schubst du in jede beliebige Rendering-Software an?
Standard-File-Formate geben sie alle an, sobald ich das so richtig sehe, 3DM, FPX, VAI, OBJ, Blend, ZTI und so.
Softimage oder Max?
Es ist ein big world of hurt, diese File-Formate, 3D-Ausdart-Formate. Autodesk hat jetzt ein bisschen in Ordnung gebracht mit diesem FPX-Format, was aber auch mittlerweile in sechs Iterationen existiert. So 2008, 2009, 2010, 2011 und nächstes kompatibel miteinander. OBJ geht halt immer, aber da gibt es halt keine Texturdaten und vor allem auch kein Textur-Map-Daten, also wie die Textur wirklich auf dem Objekt liegt mit. Also OBJ ist glaube ich 3D Max ursprünglich. Blender kann halt nur Blender lesen. Also es ist ganz, ganz furchtbar 3D Studio, 3DS ist 3D Studio, ja. OBJ ist so das, was immer geht, aber da hast du wirklich nur das rohe Modell. Da ist halt nichts dran, da ist keine Animationsinformation, keine Animation drinnen, keine Kameras drinnen, keine Lichter drinnen, keine Textur drinnen, etc.
Also malst du dann am Ende des Tages doch selbst, wenn du filmst. Aber das heißt, da setzt sich dann wirklich einer hin und mal die ganzen Props, jedes scheiß Schwert von irgendwelchen Helden oder...
Ja, also gerade im großen Film wird das alles von Grund auf neu gemacht. Es dauert auch nicht so lange, so einen Prop zu bauen. Also mit wirklich ein erfahrener 3D-Modeller baut ihr halt so ein Schwert in einer Stunde, weißt du? Also mit ornamentaligt dran und allem drum und dran. Also gerade so simple Objekte, das ist wirklich krass easy. Und Komplexobjekte machst du sowieso selber, weil da brauchst du meistens bestimmte Abmaße oder bestimmte Sachen, die explodieren müssen. Die müssen bestimmt gemodelt sein, damit sie wirklich explodieren, etc.,
Was ich hier gerade sehe, Tim klickt ja gerade bei Turboskott hier so auch lauter Personen und Gruppen an Menschen und so. Was mir letztens aufgefallen ist bei World War Z, wo sie halt auf dem Flugzeugträger zum Beispiel sind, wo sie sich da drauf retten, da siehst du ja so die dicke Ansicht von oben und dass da ganz viel los ist. Und wenn du genau hinguckst, siehst du, dass da so Personen sind, die immer so ein paar Meter laufen und dann irgendwie so 90 oder 120 Grad die Richtung wechseln, wieder ein paar Meter laufen. Also die immer so im Zickzack laufen, weil sie einfach künstliche Objekte hingesetzt haben und den Knopf gedrückt haben, ja, lauf mal so ein bisschen durch die Gegend. Aber die sind halt immer planlos, wenn du genau eine beobachtest, dann rennt die einfach planlos so durch die Gegend. Und meistens sind die Schnitte aber nicht so lange, da hast du es wirklich lange beobachten kann. Sie halten die natürlich kurz, weil sonst würdest du es sofort sehen.
Heldkrieg, da sind alle planlos.
Ja, aber guck mal, genau, die sind auch perfekt gerade und die laufen immer so ganz komisch und schwenken dabei so mit den Armen, also das siehst du sofort.
Eines der interessantesten Gebiete im VFX ist tatsächlich, diese KI jetzt dort einzubauen, gerade was so Agenten angeht, so also das, was du gerade erzählst. Da gibt es halt diese eine große Software, auch ein Maya Plugin oder Maya Edition, die heißt halt Massive, kostet 380.000 US-Dollar letztes Mal, wo ich geguckt habe. Für eine Lizenz.
Wenn du in echt filmen musst und da 5000 Extras hinstellst und Hubschrauber-Shots, das ist teurer.
Das ist schon richtig KI, das ist schon richtig interessant. Du fütterst die wirklich so mit Bewegungsdaten, die sind meistens auch mit Motion Capturing im Motion Capturing Studio aufgenommen. Dann gibst du denen halt verschiedene Uniformen, verschiedene Dinge, die blendet das dann auch miteinander. Das sind nur so 10 verschiedene Uniformen. Da kommen aber 100 verschiedene Charaktere raus. Dicker Bäuche, dünne Bäuche und so weiter. Das ist sehr, sehr random, sehr, sehr cool. Da gibt es halt wirklich Milliarden Einstellungen. Das ist aber schon fast wie so ein Spielprogramm. Da gibt es auch ganz wenig Leute, die...
Click me in army.
Click me in army. Und auch die, die dann gegeneinander kämpfen und dann kannst du sagen, wer gewinnt.
Ist das nicht ohnehin so ein Trend, dass man jetzt auch langsam anfängt, Filme mal so zu machen, wie man Computerspiele macht? Weil du hast ja gesagt, die Dinger werden ohnehin schon in 3D vorher geprototypt. Und ich weiß ja jetzt nicht so viel drüber, aber ich erinnere mich gerade an so einen Bericht, dass das offensichtlich schon so ein Trend ist, dass man sagt, das wäre eigentlich viel cooler, wenn man alles gleich in fertig gerendert mit den fertigen Texturen in Echtzeit hätte, weil dann einfach diese ganzen Post-Production-Zyklen nicht mehr hast und sehr viel schneller und dann vielleicht auch mit mehr Kontrolle ist das...
Also ich bin da definitiv der Überzeugung von, habe mir da schon sehr viel Kritik eingehandelt, gerade auch so am Filmset sollte man sowas nicht so laut sagen. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass wir davon sehr weit entfernt sind, gerade wenn man jetzt die neuen Game-Engines anguckt, so Unreal und so, da ist es sehr nah dran, das wirklich zu schaffen. Es ist natürlich immer noch das Anken, die Welle ist tief und undurchschreitbar. Das ist noch nicht ganz geklärt, wie das so mit diesen Facial-Animationen ist. Weil in dem Moment, wenn das so sehr real wird, gibt es dann noch Probleme.
Das wäre nicht einfacher, wenn man das ganze 3D-Klimbim schon mal vorher macht, und danach hat man dann so die Handpinseler, die dann aber die richtigen Personen dann sozusagen reinpinseln. Also nicht andersrum, dass das 3D auf die Personen gemalt wird. So was gab es doch auch schon, oder?
Du hast die Prives schon am Set mittlerweile. Also wenn du da wirklich so in diesem Greenscreen-Studio stehst, hast jeder Regisseur schon die realen Sachen, also Priege, da ist natürlich noch nicht die feinen Haare rausgebaut und so weiter. Aber das siehst du dann schon fertig dort am Set, so ziemlich gut mittlerweile. Das wird auch teilweise mit Game Engines gemacht, teilweise auch in diesem Maya-Viewport. Also wirklich diese Darstellung im Maya haben wir jetzt auch noch mal extrem verbessert.
Ja, das Ding ist hier, ich hab ja letztens so ein Interview mit Quentin Tarantino, beziehungsweise mit mehreren Filmleuten, und der meinte ja irgendwie, ich mach Film und analog und wenn irgendwann die Kinos nur noch digital wollen, dann mach ich halt Fernsehfilme für HBO oder so, aber ich mach nicht mehr digital irgendwie, es geht mir alles auf den Sack. Und wenn ich so diese ganzen Berichte höre, der lebt halt in seiner analogen Filmwelt alles noch ganz einfach, das kann ich mir schon ganz gut vorstellen, dass ihm das auch am Ende vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Spaß macht, weil er dann...
Ja, die Frage ist ja auch, wie es bei den Zuschauern aussieht.
Cloud Atlas ist übrigens auch mit Filmen gedreht, das war aber eine ganz bewusste Entscheidung.
Ja gut, aber der Tarantino macht ja auch sehr wenig Effekte in der Regel, oder?
Eingescannt danach, ja, und Fantino... ja, es ist halt wie mit der Analog-Fotografie. Die mögen halt ihr fucking Korn-Grain-Scheiß.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, es ist...
Und ich hasse es, wie die Pest-Frei natürlich. Es ist, wenn du einen Key machst und du rauschst halt in dem Röhrenkanal, das in allen Farben, weil du halt da diesen Grain drinne hast, dauert das halt zehnmal so lang, und dann sieht danach richtig scheiße aus, so, ne?
Ja gut, aber wenn du halt jetzt nicht große Effekte brauchst sozusagen, und mit der Rasierklinge deinen Film noch am liebsten schneidest, und trotzdem ein cooler Streifen mal rauskommt, ist ja auch gut.
Es gibt ja auch heutzutage Fotografen, die noch analog geile Fotos machen, aber es werden halt auch immer weniger. Und auch die, die wirklich drauf geschworen haben, fangen wirklich jetzt an, die Talz zu werden.
Nein, gut, das ist auch eine Qualitätsfrage, weil du jetzt natürlich auch mit zu Gigapixel und so weiter in Bereiche vordringst, wo halt die analogen Methoden überhaupt nicht mehr...
Ja, ich meine auch halt das, was früher vielleicht billig war, Film entwickeln lassen, da die Preise steigen ja jetzt, oder? Es gibt ja gar keine... Gibt es in Berlin noch Buden, die Analogfilme entwickeln? Aber die werden immer weniger aussichern. Und die Preise sind da bestimmt nicht gesunken, sondern die steigen. Weil du bist jetzt schon ein Special-Wetter dahin gehst.
Filmmaterial wird tatsächlich nicht mehr produziert. Das ist alles, was jetzt noch auf richtig Film 35 Millimeter gedreht wird, 16 sowieso, schon lange nicht mehr, ist alles Material, was noch in irgendwelchen Kellern liegt, was dazu führt, dass du extreme Bugs in diesem Filmmaterial hast, weil das natürlich umso länger es lagert, umso mehr Bugs es kriegt und das jetzt auch nicht mehr so die A-Ware ist.
So wie Polaroids gibt es ja auch gar keine mehr, ist alles schon vorbei.
Zum Beispiel bei Claude Althalast im Blaukanal, da war halt die blaue Emulsion fast durch den gesamten Film beschädigt und hast halt immer im Blaukanal so einen echten... Wir gucken uns halt wirklich die einzelnen Kanäle an und dann denkst du halt, was machst du falsch? Da geht es wirklich um Pixel. Und dann denkst du halt, irgendwas ist da nicht in Ordnung. Und da liegt es halt, dann guckt man halt, woran es wirklich liegt.
Und du denkst schon, du bist jetzt schon so lange vor dem Rechner, dass du jetzt schlieren siehst für deinen kreisigen Augen.
Dass du schon so einen Claude Althalast vor den Augen hast.
Ich muss halt auch immer diese Abnahmen machen und gucke mir die ganze Zeit nur auf diese Pixel. Und dann, wenn dann sowas ist, dann zweifelst du an dir selber oder auch an deinen Artists, weil du denkst, die haben irgendwelche Scheiße gemacht.
Falk, ich muss jetzt mal versuchen, den Bogen mal so ein bisschen in eine andere Richtung zu kriegen. Aber ich will auf etwas eingehen, was du schon gesagt hast, und zwar diese MARI-Software. Ich lade gerade mal hier diesen Vortrag nochmal runter, um da vielleicht mal einen Blick zu erhaschen. Aber da steht ja, dass es sozusagen deshalb auf der WWDC gezeigt wurde, weil es auch ein Showcase ist für eine zukünftige Anwendung auf dem neuen Mac Pro, also die von der Architektur besonders profitiert. Du bist ja jetzt jemand, der extrem viel mit diesem High-End-Programm arbeitet und gearbeitet hat und du kennst ja diese ganzen Performance-Problematiken. Ich weiß gar nicht, was kannst du alles so aus dem FF? Klar, Photoshop, du hast mit After Effects, glaube ich, viel gearbeitet, Illustrator.
Nuke ist so das große Compositing-Programm, das kann ich sehr gut. Also früher war es so Shake. Genau, Shake, was ja Apple gekauft hat auch, ne? Genau, dann hat Apple das so ein bisschen fallen lassen. Das war so ganz tragisch für mich und viele andere, die sich dieses Programm sehr zu Herzen genommen hatten. Und das Replacement ist sozusagen Nuke von The Foundry, ist so ein kleines anderes Auto, der Skadobe. Wir haben hier mittlerweile einen Monopol auf diese Compositing-Software, weil die die Einzelne haben, die noch irgendwie gebraucht wird. Dann halt Maya natürlich, also viele 3D-Programme, Maya, Modo, Siebwatsch, Mudbox, bla, also den ganzen Kram.
Genau, und da hast du bestimmt immer irgendwelche Performance-Probleme gehabt, oder?
Also wie gesagt, wo du vorhin sagst, das ist ein ernstes Thema. Im Moment halte ich einen Mac Pro 8-Core, weiß ich nicht, mit einer GTX 570, glaube ich, drinnen.
So eine Nvidia-Karte.
Nicht geflasht, muss ich auch dazu sagen, weil in den Firmen, wo ich arbeite, sind natürlich 100 Prozent Windows. VFX, traditionell Windows-Domäne. Die einzige Firma, wo ich gearbeitet habe, wo kein Windows war, war in Toronto, wo ich an Harry Potter gearbeitet habe, da gab es CentOS.
Und die schicken trotzdem Festplatten mit HFS Plus-Format durch die Gegend, oder was?
Nein, kein HFS Plus, das war ein Filmset, da stehen wirklich die Lappies so, der Dit hat meistens hier so ein Mac Pro herumstellen und da wird so Mac. Also die ganze Post ist natürlich Mac-basiert, da gibt es so Avidz, also schon lange kein Final Cut mehr, gibt es so Avidz und so weiter, und da ist das alles HFS Plus, aber schon in den VFX-Buden ist Windows. Ich zu Hause mache ja auch eigenes Zuhause und auch zum Vorbereiten und so. Ich habe halt schon in den 90ern mich gequält und habe 3D auf Mac gemacht, war wahrscheinlich die einzige Mensch auf dieser Welt, der ausschließlich auf Mac, nee, war ich nicht, weil ich wusste, ich hatte ja auch einigen Communities drin, die auch so gelitten hatten. 2001 gab es ja dann Maya für den Mac, ab da wurde es ein bisschen besser. Vorher war das alles extrem anstrengend. Ich habe jetzt einen Mac Pro, konnte mich bis heute nicht durchbeißen, wirklich eine Windows-Maschine unter meinen Tisch zu stellen, weil dann natürlich mein ganzer Workflow hinüber ist. Das ist schon schön, so einen Mac zu haben, weil natürlich alles mit dem Server und so, ich muss überhaupt kein bisschen Systematisationen machen, das läuft halt alles irgendwie seit Jahren stabil und irgendwie, du musst dir nichts kümmern. Es ist halt auch immer noch sehr absturzarm, wenn man so eine Windows-Maschine, die lockt schon öfter mal. Das ist schon ein deutlicher Unterschied. Das erweitert mich nicht mehr so schlimm, wie es mal war, aber es macht keinen Spaß, auch so Dateien zu kopieren und multiple Desktop und so, diese ganze Nummer. Dafür habe ich halt einen Mac. Dann kam jetzt Apple mit diesem Mac Pro.
Was denkst du darüber?
Ja, mit der Tonne, mit dem Mülleimer. Tischmülleimer bitte. Also meine initiale Reaktion war, um Gottes Willen, ich wollte einen etwas kleineren Rechner mit wesentlich mehr Power haben. Apple hat einen wesentlich kleineren Rechner mit nur ein wenig mehr Power mir präsentiert.
Also ein bisschen mehr CPU-Power.
Ein bisschen mehr CPU-Power. Naja, das weiß man noch nicht so genau.
Vor allem bei den Sachen, mit denen du arbeitest, brauchst du auch mehr IOP-Power. CPU alleine tut das nicht. Wenn du allein für das Kopieren deiner Arbeitssituationen dort wie fünf Stunden brauchst, weil es durch irgendwelche Interfaces durchnuckelt, dann nützt du das auch nicht mit deiner Bilderdoppel zwischen den Rändern.
Wenn da doch eine SSD drin hat mit Gigabyte-Durchsatz, dann brauchst du doch auch wieder rum, aber die CPU, die das handeln kann, nützt auch wieder nichts.
Ja, ist klar, das muss beides hochgehen. Aber CPU alleine ist auch für ein Problem.
Richtig.
Vielleicht jetzt nicht so...
Meine North Bridge ist definitiv... Ich höre sie auch bei mir zu Hause. Die fiept, ja. Das ist der Voltage Regulator, ja. Aber auf jeden Fall, wenn da richtig Durchsatz ist, egal was, ob jetzt die Grafikkarte im Anspruch wird oder die SSDs, die ich auch drin habe oder sonst irgendwas, fängt das halt an zu fiepen. Das ist schon der Durchsatz, der hakt schon bei dem Mac Pro, den ich unter dem Tisch habe, wahrscheinlich am meisten. Natürlich ist das CPU, wenn ich renne, da ist immer Vollausschlag, alle acht an. Und die Grafikkarte ist natürlich, wenn du große Modelle einlädst, ein Mal ja auch am Ende ihrer... Ich hatte halt eine Quadro drin, die ist wirklich kaputtgegangen, überhitzt und abgeschmiert für 2800 Euro oder so. Danach stehst du halt auch da mit so einem Mac Pro und überlegst dir, was geholtest du denn jetzt? Dann gibt es halt nix. Also die KW100 gibt es jetzt, glaube ich, KW1000 oder so. Kostet halt auch wieder 2300 oder so. Dann hast du so eine drei Jahre alte Grafikkarte. Und deswegen habe ich dann halt auf diese nicht geflashte... Da war ich sehr froh, dass es seit zwei, seit zehn Punkten, was war es danach? Du weißt das doch bestimmt. Kannst du jetzt so ungeflashte Grafikkarten reintun, ne?
Ja, so manche. Aber ich habe immer noch eine 5870 auch ungeflasht drin. Hab dadurch keinen Bootscreen. Der Name wird falsch angezeigt. Das könnte man wohl noch fixen. Aber ich hätte gerne auch irgendwie was Besseres. Aber alles, was es da gibt, das funktioniert wohl schon. Und Bootscreen geht wohl auch. Aber da gibt es halt noch so Sachen, die default Bildschirmauflösung passt sich nicht dein Monitor an. Das heißt, die gehen auf default auf 2500, obwohl ich jetzt nur einen mit 1920 habe. Und das ist beim Finder okay. Aber wenn du ein Spiel starten würdest, nicht. Weil das kommt dann in einer falschen Auflösung. Das kostet dich dann wieder OpenGL Performance und so weiter. Und außerdem, es ist einfach nicht perfekt. Und dann kann ich auch weiter mit meiner Lösung rumeiern, die ich habe. Und ich weiß nicht, ob da ehemals noch was kommen wird. Also auch diese Zafir-Card hat auch dieses Auflösungsproblem. Das ist der falsche Default. Das gefällt mir nicht.
Aber das ist doch nur eine Einstellung, die man einmal ändert und dann ist gut, oder?
Ja, beim Finder aber nicht, wenn sich so ein Spiel startet. Das Spiel will ja dann die native Auflösung nehmen und geht dann auf 2500, obwohl ich nur 1920 habe.
Okay, aber wenn man keine Spiele spielt, ist alles okay.
Dann brauchst du so eine Card eh nicht.
Ja, es sei denn du machst 3D und willst ja nicht irgendwie so eine alte Nvidia reinstecken für einen überteuerten Preis.
Sag mal, wenn du hier der 3D-Spielstier bist, hier bei den Bitcoins. Ich habe ja so einige AMD-Karten.
Nee, nee.
Warte, warte, hör mal zu Ende. Aber bei Bitcoins waren diese AMD-Karten richtig gut. Die Nvidias konnten da gar nicht mithalten. Ist es im 3D-Bereich eigentlich auch so oder ist es da genau andersrum?
Also ich habe sehr viele Probleme mit AMD-Karten grundsätzlich gehabt. Maya hat ganze Zeit lang nicht offiziell AMD-Karten gar nicht unterstützt.
Da sagt man ja immer, dass die so scheiße Treiber haben, richtig?
Ja, es geht nicht nur um die Treiber, es geht halt auch darum, ob es die Treiber sind oder sonst was, die sind nie flüssig gewesen. Also wirklich dieser Fluss auch mal beim Video abspielen und so. Du merkst halt immer, bei den AMD habe ich immer dieses Stattern gehabt, immer über Jahre hinweg, über verschiedene Maschinen hinweg, was war immer dieses, es war nicht... Also wenn du dann eine Nvidia dagegen hast, das ist alles viel smoother, das ist alles viel... Auch ein 3D-Modell drehen, diese Millisekunden anfassen, das ist alles instant so. Genau, das könnte man schon so sagen. Ich bin da technisch nicht drin, aber vom Gefühl her waren diese Nvidia immer viel stabiler, auch wesentlich glitchfreier. Also Maya ist dann auch oft abgestürzt mit diesen AMD-Grafikkarten. Und das war immer so. Deswegen, weil es Apple jetzt gesagt hat, hier... Na ja, mit 102 AMDs rein, dachte ich so, ach du Kacke. Also natürlich sind wir jetzt ganz woanders. Die Grafikkarten sind generell viel viel schneller geworden. Es gibt jetzt erste Benchmarks, halt auch nicht mit denen, aber mit den FirePro W8000, 7000 und so weiter, die die auch gegen diese Nvidia pitchen. Die OpenGL Performance scheint tatsächlich besser zu sein als bei den Nvidia. Die OpenCL Performance ist allerdings auf dieser Nvidia, wie heißt sie gleich, diese 1000 Euro Nvidia, die Titan doch gleichauf für einen wesentlich günstigeren Preis. Also die Titan hat ja AMD so ein bisschen die Füße weggerissen, weil die kamen ja aus nirgendwo, die kamen ja auch zwei Monate, nachdem sie ihre Flagship rausgebracht hatten, auf den Markt geworfen, keiner wusste, wo es herkam.
Aber da hat ja AMD jetzt nachgelegt mit dieser R9 290X oder so. Für den halben Preis kommt die wohl ziemlich nah an die Titan ran.
Okay, aber die ist ja jetzt nicht in dem Mac Pro drinnen?
Nein, ich weiß noch nicht, was genau in dem Mac Pro eigentlich drin ist, weil das ist ja irgendwie eine ganz andere Sorte als eine Konsumagrafikkarte. Und mir ist da noch nicht so klar, wo da die Unterschiede sind und was es nun da genau mit auf sich hat.
Ich habe da vorhin nämlich mal gegoogelt, weil ich mich ja ein bisschen vorbereitet hatte, wusste ja schon, dass das kommt. Dort spekulieren sie tatsächlich, dass diese drei Abstufungen auch wirklich parallel gehen zu diesen W5000, W7000.
Apple hat es irgendwie mit 200, 400, 600 oder so was gemacht.
Und dann gibt es dann halt von AMD diese Fire Pro 5000, 7000 und 8000.
Ja, aber am Ende sind doch exakt die gleichen Chips drin, oder nicht?
Ja.
Also es ist auch wieder nur so eine Treibergeschichte.
Und eine Anschlussgeschichte, was ich ihnen ja noch viel mehr vorhalte. Also dass sie da einen neuen fucking Connector bauen für so eine Grafikkarte. Na das ist ja kein PCIe Standard-Connector.
Achso, weil es im Mac Pro fest verbaut ist?
Nein, fest verbaut ist er nicht. Du kannst das schon rausnehmen. Und du kannst es wohl auch wirklich in eine andere rein schrauben. Aber der muss natürlich eine sein, die da reinpasst. Also vom Connector her. Also vom Anschluss her.
Ich dachte, das ist sowieso halt irgendein proprietärer Apple-Connector, den sonst sowieso gar keiner macht, weil es gehäusemäßig so vorgegeben ist. Und die haben einfach die GPU da festgelötet. Du meinst, dass es halt...
Nee, es ist schon eine Karte, die auf dem Connector steckt. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ja, das sind Karten. Das sind ganz normale Grafikkarten, die bloß einen anderen Anschluss haben.
Aha, ich dachte, das wäre einfach so ein eigenes Mainboard.
Und das ist auch definitiv kein PCI, nur dass man es in einer anderen Anordnung ist.
Das weiß man nicht.
Das könnte ja glatt sein.
Das könnte glatt sein, ja. Ich nehme es auch an, dass es so ist.
Geil, da kann man eine rausnehmen und dann so eine High Power 100 Gigabit Netzerkarte so hochkant reinstecken. Und den Deckel lässt man einfach gleich weg dann.
Okay, aber was machst du dir jetzt für einen Reim aus diesem Trend, dass hier eigentlich die Grafikkarte die viel größere Rolle spielt als die CPU?
Macht halt für Grafik, also für meinen Bereich natürlich, viel Sinn. Es gibt viele Renderer, die mittlerweile auch stark auf die Grafikkarte zugreifen. V-Ray ist da so ein ganz gutes Beispiel. Das sind wirklich so Performance Increases von so zehnfache.
Nutzen die dann auch alle OpenCL dann dafür?
Die nutzen bisher alle CUDA dafür.
Aber im Prinzip ist das ja alles portierbar auf OpenCL.
Portierbar, Adobe hat es ja gerade vorgemacht. Die hatten ja lange Zeit nur CUDA, auch After Effects und so weiter. Die machen jetzt ab CS6, glaube ich, oder so machen die ja auch zu OpenCL. Und was ich aber trotzdem problematisch finde, also es ist natürlich auch eine Preisfrage, wenn man sich so die Workstations auf der PC-Seite anguckt, da gibt es eigentlich nur noch zwei Hersteller, die man so als VFX-Firma unter den Tisch der Artes stellt. Das ist einmal HP mit dieser Z800-820-Serie und dann diese Box Technologies. Das ist so eine kleine Bude, die nur für so High-End-Grafik-Workstation bauen im Prinzip. Und da sind die Preise, die fangen halt so bei 6.500 Dollar an, gehen dann hoch so bis, wenn du so eine Maschine speckst, so bis 12. Und da sind halt auch Dual-Core, Intel, Xeons drinne, also bei der 12er-Variante dann mit irgendwie auch zwei High-End-Grafikkarten und so. Wenn Apple das jetzt gemacht hätte, dann hätten alle gesagt, habt ihr eine Scheibe. Aber eigentlich sind das schon so die Pro-Grafik-Workstation, die auch in allen Firmen unter dem Tisch stehen. Also das hätte Apple noch locker machen können. Ich weiß nicht, warum sie jetzt nur so...
Also du hättest auch lieber wieder so eine Standardkiste mit PCI-Slots, wo man ein bisschen was zu umrüsten kann.
Standardkiste mit PCI-Slots und auch zwei Prozessoren. Weil für mich ist halt Renderzeit wirklich wichtig und ich will nicht eine zweite Renderkiste da stehen haben. Ich möchte das in einer Kiste machen.
Wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel in Apple-Weg gehen, würden wir jetzt nur Final Cut und sowieso alles ohne. Und die, ihre Software, sowieso alles auf... Final Cut, wie auch immer. Also wenn du so ein Prosumer bist, sagen wir mal, ne? Und du schnibbelst da jetzt so mit deinen Filmchen rum, machst vielleicht einen Werbespot damit oder so. Und deren Software ist jetzt so komplett auf Grafik, Power dann auch ausgelegt. Und dann ist es gar nicht so wichtig mehr, so viel CPUs zu haben. Also wenn sie jetzt halt wirklich... Ich mein, sie könnten jetzt ja sagen, irgendwie, gut, wir ignorieren jetzt einfach mal die ganz krasse Profi-Nischenecke, in Anführungsstrichen.
Ja, also Final Cut ist... Also das können wir komplett erstmal hier außer Diskussion streichen. Final Cut gibt's nicht mehr. Also es gibt's schon noch, aber es benutzt halt keiner mehr. Das ist alles, was Final Cut hat.
Ist das schon länger so oder mit dem neuen X?
Mit dem neuen X, da haben sie sich richtig aus dem Rennen geschossen. Also alle Pro-User, die richtig high-end Pro-User sind, sind zurück zu Avid gegangen, was furchtbar ist, weil die Firma so arrogant und so furchtbar, dass ich immer gehofft hatte, dass sie die Greife... Ja, mit proprietären Festplatten, die irgendwie 10-fache kosten. Also wirklich ganz schlimm. Also wirklich ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz furchtbar. Die werden da auch wieder hinkommen. Also die haben sich mal ein bisschen geöffnet eine Weile. Dann haben sie auch externe Festplatten zugelassen. Als Final Cut kamen. Ja, aber jetzt fangen sie schon wieder an, in die Serials Final Cut kamen. Jetzt fangen sie aber schon wieder an. Wenn man jetzt zu Server, können sie gar nicht.
Das machen die doch nur, um die User-Zufriedenheit zu sichern.
Natürlich. Und die Prosumer...
Ich liebe euch alle!
Die Prosumer, die halt nicht auf Avid gehen, weil es natürlich auch eine Kostenfrage ist, die sind halt alle auf Premiere umgestiegen und Premiere hat einen solchen Quantensprung gemacht in den letzten zwei Jahren, dass es wirklich ein dermaßen benutzbares Programm geworden ist. Ich stehe da total drauf. Das kann halt alles, was Final Cut kann, mit 20-facher Geschwindigkeit. Und ist halt sehr schön. Das ist leider ein Adore-Produkt.
20-facher Geschwindigkeit und Final Cut Pro X?
Du kannst 10 Streams, HD machen, selbst aus meiner alten Kiste zu Hause. Das macht einfach Spaß. Das hat Final Cut nie gemacht. Und Final Cut X geht halt vom Interferse.
Ich fand das eigentlich ganz cool, aber ich bin ja auch kein richtiger.
Wenn du da von null auf einsteigst, hab ich auch mit Final Cut X rumgemacht. Wenn du das vorher jahrelang gemacht hast, das ist genauso, wie wenn jetzt jemand hingeht und mir sagt, nee, VI darfst du nicht mehr benutzen. Du nimmst jetzt bitte den clicky-bunty-Editor.
Niemals!
VI oder tot.
Ja, aber was heißt denn das jetzt? Also denkst du, dass der Mac Pro irgendwie ein bold move ist? Oder ist das irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, oder geht da der Trend hin? Nehmen Sie da jetzt irgendwie die richtige Fahrt auf? Ist Rendering zu Hause überhaupt noch ein Thema oder lässt man nicht sowieso im Netz rendern?
Kommt immer aufs Projekt drauf an. Also ich hatte schon eine sehr schöne, extrem starke Maschine unterm Tisch. Und erinnere dich auch, wo ich mal in zwei Jahren, wenn die Grafikkarten wieder dreimal so schnell sind, ohne dass ich die gleiche ganze Maschine auseinandernehme, weil Intel halt mittlerweile sehr langsam ist mit ihren Prozessor-Upgrades, einfach die Grafikkarte austauschen könnte, das wäre total super. Ich habe am Anfang extrem Probleme gehabt mit dem Rechner. Ich finde ihn mittlerweile nicht mehr so schlimm, weil wie gesagt, diese Benchmarks von den Grafikkarten, wenn das so stimmt, wenn es wirklich diese W8, W7000 und W5000 Grafikkarten sind, sind die okay. Ich finde den Rechner, also wie gesagt, Festplatten kann man eh extern heranschließen, hast du eh einen Rate heutzutage irgendwie dran. Also ich hätte gerne eine zweite CPU drin, also wenigstens die Option drauf.
Warum jetzt noch eine zweite CPU? Ich meine, du schreist doch nach Cores, nicht nach CPUs.
Oder noch mehr Cores, aber...
Aber es gibt ja da auch mehr als ein Core.
Jaja, aber jetzt habe ich acht so und möglich wären halt...
Nee, zwölf ist das Maximum.
Ja, jetzt habe ich acht, dann könnte ich jetzt upgraden auf zwölf.
Also du hast ein Dual-Quad, richtig? Und da ist aber nur ein Single-Hexer drin? Ja, und er hätte gerne Dual-Hexer, so wie die Mac Pros die letztes Jahr auch hatten, richtig?
Ja.
Die letzten Mac Pros hier, die großen Klopper hatten Dual-Hexer.
Nee, die Dual-12 hatten die nicht. Möglich ist, zwei mal zwölf, möglich ist sogar vier mal zwölf mit den neuen Xeons zu haben. Also die neuen Xeons sind ja die ersten, die wieder mehr als zwei Prozessoren noch drin hast. Das ist natürlich auch eine Preisfrage, das kann sich ja keiner leisten, aber ein Dual-12er wäre schon schön. Und mit einem 24-Course, da könnte ich echt eine Menge zu Hause machen, ohne jetzt vielleicht einen Rendermann und Iman zu mieten. Also natürlich Cloud-Rendering für größere Projekte ist super interessant.
Aber dafür reichen aber die Strippen in Deutschland nicht.
Nee, das ist sehr interessant. Das Rendering selber ist tatsächlich sehr interessant, weil du hast ja nicht so die riesen Datenmengen. Also schiebst du da schon einmal so 2-3 GB je nach Szene nach oben. Das dauert halt 2-3 Stunden. Und dann kommen die Bilder aber einzeln zurück. Und das sind dann immer nur so 8,6 MB oder so. Vielleicht sind es auch mal 100 MB, aber dauert ja dann auch.
Ja, laden geht ja dann schon.
Solange du sie noch schneller laden kannst, als der sie rendert. Was hast du da für Rendering-Timestamps pro Frame?
Die Cloudsachen sind interessant. Das Rendermann und der Mann greift auf die Renderform von Pixel auf. Natürlich hast du da Renderzeiten, die sind zu vernachlässigen. Aber es ist natürlich auch eine Preisfrage.
Wie ist denn da das Preismodell? Nur so grob. Ich will jetzt keine Dollars, aber wie geht das für ein Projekt?
Das ist das Preismodell. Es geht pro CPU-Stunde.
Das heißt, es geht jetzt nicht pro Främe, weil das kann ja beliebig komplex sein. Es geht pro CPU-Stunde.
Du kannst dann auch so High-Performance oder Low-Performance mieten, also je nachdem wie dringend es ist, dass du das zurückkriegst. Aber selbst die Low-Performance ist...
Du mietest da aber nicht die Roh-CPU, sondern wirklich die Funktionalität. Ich kann also jetzt nicht sagen, ach, ich schubs da mal drin, dass man mit den Dingen Bitcoin rechnen soll oder so.
Das sind wirklich Render-Services, die wirklich nur mit so bestimmten Renderern auch zusammenarbeiten. Also da liest du dann so ein RIP-File hoch. So ein Render mein RIP-File und dann sagst du dir hier, Rende mal bitte.
Das ist ja wirklich eine ganz verrückte Welt.
Ja, und der Mac Pro... Ich hatte das erste Gefühl, weil das jetzt schlimmer ist. Mittlerweile habe ich mich ein bisschen damit angefreundet. Ich finde den Preis noch ein bisschen übertrieben für Ditwadet.is. Also wie gesagt, natürlich sind die PC-Workstations auch extrem teuer, aber die können halt auch wirklich mehr. Da ist mehr RAM drin, da ist die zweite CPU drin. Ja, und mehr ist flexibler halt. Du kannst mehr Festplatten dran tun, das Muzzle Board ist wesentlich größer. Aber das passt halt mehr ran. Keine Ahnung, hast mehrere PCI-Lanes etc. Kann natürlich das alles irgendwie an ihrem Thunderbolt da aus dem Ranhänger. Wenn ich so scheiß Stecker sehe, ich weiß nicht, ob ich da mein ganzes Studio da irgendwie da was ranhängen möchte.
Ja, Unlocking-Stecker, da weiß ich auch echt nicht, was ich davon halten soll. Ich meine, wo ist das Problem? Kann man nicht mal, wenn man so ein geiles Interface hat, dann einfach mal so einen Lock da ran machen? Ist ja nicht so, dass das nicht schon erfunden wäre. Das ist mir wirklich ein totales Rätsel und das ist auch so meine Angst. Ich finde jetzt auch bei meinem Mac Pro, ich habe da einfach alles drin. Die Platten sind da drin, sogar noch ein DVD-Laufwerk. Also ich meine, irgendwo braucht man ja eins, aber das würde ich dann auch nicht irgendwie rumstehen lassen. Ja, braucht man. Und ja, ist toll.
Wie gesagt, Konsens in der VFX-Community, oder generell Leuten, die halt auch zu Hause viel VFX machen, die meisten VFX-Artists machen das ja auch für zu Hause, noch so kleinere Projekte und so, sagen halt alle, ja, wir hätten uns gerne eine etwas kleinere Maschine mit wesentlich mehr Funktionalität, mit wesentlich mehr Power gewünscht und Apple hat uns eine wesentlich kleinere Maschine mit wenig mehr Power gegeben. Und es gibt halt schon so Benchmarks hier, Cinebench und so, von der Maschine, die floten da irgendwie durchs Netz. Wir sind halt 25 Prozent schneller als der letzte Mac Pro, also so richtig doll ist es halt nicht.
Aber für was ist denn die Maschine viel schneller? Also ich meine, ist dann Final Cut rendern sehr viel schneller, ist dann Logic-Spuren rendern schneller, sind dann Computer-Spieler.
Also es sind schon so schnellere Grafikkarten, als du jetzt in so ein Mac Pro reinbauen kannst. Aber es sind bei weitem nicht die schnellsten. Weiß man nicht, ob das die schnellsten Grafikkarten sind.
Ich frage mich halt so, in welcher Range sozusagen, da der Rechner sozusagen so Leute überzeugen soll, zu investieren. Also welche Gruppe von Kreativen sozusagen, auf welchem Niveau?
Also es steht dann schon so in Werbeagenturen. Ich arbeite auch, es ist halt viel für Werbung, weil es natürlich im Filmbusiness nicht so viel Geld gibt. Werbung ist ein bisschen besser so bezahlt. Und da gucke ich halt auch immer an diese kleinen Werbebuden, die halt so Fernsehwerbung machen. Und da steht dann halt immer mal so ein Event mit so einem Mac Pro rum. Oder generell auch alles, was irgendwie die Publishing ist, auch Webpublishing und so. Die werden halt alle Tausende von diesen Dingern kaufen, weil die warten halt auch so ein bisschen mal drauf. Also alle, die so ein bisschen mehr brauchen als so ein iMac.
Wobei ja die iMacs eigentlich auch schon ganz schön......
Beaster sind.
Beaster sind, ja.
Wurden jetzt auch übergangsweise überall gekauft, aber vom Gefühl her sagen halt immer alle so, das ist jetzt nicht so der Pro-Rechner. Also man möchte jetzt dafür...
Man will zuhause, wenn man profimäßig arbeitet, dann will man so ein Big Iron unterm Tisch haben.
Und nicht auf.
Ja, ich meine, also das Einzige, was mich am iMac...
Aber er sieht auch so schick aus....
meinte das Einzige, was mich sozusagen davon abhält, also Mac Mini ist halt zu schwach auf der Brust in vielerlei Hinsicht. iMac hat halt das Display eingebaut, und ich steh nicht so auf diese klobigen, spiegelnden Displays. Deswegen ist da sozusagen der Mac Pro wiederum so genau dazwischen eigentlich so ganz nett, aber wiederum Nachteile vom iMac trotzdem mit drin und auch noch arschteuer. Also ich weiß ja nicht, was der Top-of-the-Line-iMac kostet, aber das können wir ja gleich mal rausfinden.
Was ich mich frage, hier im Store, gibt's die nur mit 6-Core, haben die nicht was von 12-Core gesagt?
Ja, die haben was von 12-Core gesagt.
Der hat 6-Core und mit 12-Core hast du 12. So läuft es heutzutage.
Marketing-Shit. Meinst du echt? Das wäre aber wirklich fatal.
Auf den Bildern ist da nur ein Kern zu sehen. Also ein Chip.
Ja, aber es gibt doch die Intel CPUs mit 12-Cores mittlerweile. Also die neuen Intel CPUs haben noch 12-Cores.
Ja, das werden sie vielleicht ja nochmal updaten. Hier ist ja noch nicht mal der Configure-Button.
Diese 3999 sind auch wirklich mit der kleinsten Grafikkarte.
Aber wenn es ein richtiger 12-Kerne mit Hyper-Setting 24 wäre, dann wäre der nicht nur 25% schneller.
Vielleicht gibt es ja hier auch...
Der müsste 25% schon schneller sein, wenn der neue Xeon nur mit auch 8-Kernen so wie deiner. Dann müsste der 25% schneller sein. Das heißt, das ist halt so ein 6-Kerneteil mit Hyper-Setting, und der ist 25% schneller.
Das bedeutet, dass du den Configurable-to-3-GHz-8-Core-Processor, also du kannst einen 8-Kern Xeon dir mit 3 GHz und Boost auf 3,9 GHz... Nee, Quatsch, Moment.
Wir warten, glaube ich, mal wirklich ab, bis dieses Teil kommt.
Oder ein 2,7 GHz 12-Core-Processor. Mit 30 MB Level 3.
Also ein Build-to-Order wird es das schon noch geben.
Also es gibt dann 6, 8 und 12. Alle als Single-CPU.
Und hier die Grafikkarten kannst du Configurable auf AMD Fire Pro D700 dual...
300, 500, 700, das waren die Zahlen. Nicht 200, 400, 600.
Wie gesagt, Akitosh, das ist halt so die Seite für Architekten, die auf dem Mac arbeiten, also auch mit 3D. Die meint halt, dass das von den Specks her sehr ähnlich dieser W800, W8000, W7000 und W5000 ist.
Auch was das V-Rahmen betrifft, ich meine, wir haben ja bis zu 6 Gigabyte...
Wozu brauchst du denn das V-Rahmen bei einer Grafikkarte?
Ja, das kann ich dir nicht sagen, das frage ich dich.
Da hast du die Texturen reingeladen, oder?
Das geht um Texturen reinladen, ja. Und das brauchst du eigentlich nur in 3D-Applikationen.
Für OpenCL ist das alles gar kein Thema?
Das weiß ich nur wiederum nicht. Inwiefern die Programm-Teile dort auf den V-Rahmen rechnen, das kann ich mir nicht sagen.
Ich würde schon auch sagen, dass du deine Daten damit hochlädst.
Aber da brauchst du aber nicht so viel, weil das ja eh nur kleine Chunks sind, die du da immer berechnest.
Ja, aber jeder Chunk kann ja auf einem anderen Teil vom Bild rechnen. Deswegen kannst du das doch parallelisieren. Wenn alle auf dem gleichen Teil im Bild rechnen würden, das würde ja nicht gehen. Das heißt, du gibst an jedem Stream den eigenen Bildbereich. Du machst einfach dein Blur-Filter in OpenCL, dann sagst du hier, du da, du da. Und dann legen die da rüber und sind fertig.
Kannst halt ganz viele Fremster reinballern und dann wird da halt drauf rumgejuckelt. Keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht. Wir werden es sehen. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich meine, sie werden sich schon ein bisschen was dabei gedacht haben.
Wie gesagt, eine 6 GB für deine Texturen, die musst du da erstmal raufkriegen auf die Grafikkarte. Das ist halt, das merkt man in Maya, immer schön, wenn du eine große Textur hast. Und du möchtest wirklich mal die in hoher Qualität sehen, weil du musst sehen, ob die wirklich an einer bestimmten Ecke passt. Also, dass du da nicht nur so eine 256 x 256 Abbildung hast mit Treppchen, sondern wirklich die volle 4K-Textur, die du da raufschmeißt. Dann wartest du da erst mal, bis die Textur auf die Grafikkarte raufgeladen ist.
Aber die Textur wird schnell da sein, dann kommt die langsam von der Platte, oder? Also ich meine, für die Grafikkarten kannst du mit 30 GB die Sekunde schieben. Das kann nicht das Problem sein. Das ist eher das Laden.
Das kommt von der SSD, also eigentlich...
Ich meine, das Ding hat eine... In den Specks steht 264 GB pro Sekunde Memory Bandwidth.
Das ist aber normaler Speicher, nicht zur Grafikkarte. Aber kannst ja gucken, bei dieser R992X AMD, das ist normaler Consumer-Shit, da stand, glaube ich, was von 30 GB die Sekunde zur...
Aber geht das da durch?
Nein, 240 GB die Memory Bandwidth von den Grafikkarten. Ach so, innerhalb der Grafikkarte sind es 240 GB.
Innerhalb, ja, okay.
Quatsch, das ist alles innerhalb, was ich hier lese. Aber ich weiß auch nicht, wie schnell die angebunden sind an das System.
Also, wir müssen mal noch abwarten, dass er draußen ist. Die ersten Leute da mal Final Cut Pro ordentlich drauf benutzen.
Aber das ist ja auch eigentlich ganz einfach. Du brauchst doch nur die PCI-Express-Specs angucken. Da steht ja da, wie schnell die Maxima können. Die haben dann 16 Lanes bei so und so viel. Und dann steht da genau da, wie viel der überhaupt Maxima rübergehen könnte.
Also du sagst in Premiere, ja, ist das Shit. Ich finde ja, Final Cut Pro X ist jetzt das iMovie, wie es schon immer hätte sein sollen. Also ich finde, unter dem Aspekt benutzt sich das eigentlich sehr cool und hat halt auch die ganzen Features, die iMovies nicht hat. So wie jetzt uns dieses tolle Feature von Clip-Synchronisieren gefunden, wo man Audio- und Bilderquellen unterschiedlicher Sorte so mit einem Klick perfekt synchronisiert kriegt, was es in iMovie wahrscheinlich nie geben wird. Obwohl es wahrscheinlich in allen anderen Programmen so ein Trivialfeature ist. Aber da sind halt so diese ganzen Features drin, um mal wirklich...
Ja, diese One-Click-Features, aber wenn du wirklich schneiden möchtest, wenn du wirklich einen Überblick über deinen Schnitt behalten möchtest, also auch schnell in der Timeline hin und her scrollen und dann halt auch mal Sachen mal schnell eben farbkorrigieren. Und also diesen ganzen Kram, das ist halt... Allaat-Premiere ganz, ganz weit genau so vor. Weil es gerade im Chat kam, ich weiß nicht mehr, wo die Benchmarks waren. Das ist schon echt ein paar Monate her.
Ja, wenn es nicht Adobe Software wäre...
Wo waren diese Scene-Event?
Also wenn ich das hier richtig verstehe mit dem PCI Express, das ist alles schnell genug. Das ist schon so die Bandbreite, die sie da irgendwie zu dieser Grafikkarte...
Was sagt denn das PCI Express?
Was soll es denn sonst sein?
Nee, was sagt das, wie schnell es ist?
Ich bin mir gerade nicht so sicher, aber hier ist von... Ich weiß nicht, welche Versionen sie da reinbauen, aber PCI...
Das wird wohl PCI Express 3.0 sein, weil wenn die jetzt da noch 2.0 verbauen, dann werden die ja ausgelacht. Ich meine, die werden eh schon immer ausgelacht, aber...
Hier ist von 8 Gigatransfers per second die Rede, aber ich weiß nicht, was das bedeutet.
Ja, aber pro Lane oder was? Gigatransfers heißt halt... Der Bus hat ja eine Breite und das ist halt nicht Bits oder Bytes, sondern die schicken ja so ein bisschen größere Chunks dadurch. 32, 64, 128, 28.
PCIe 3.0, also 8 Giga-Transfer, Bits Rate, Effectively Delivers, 985 Megabyte pro Sekunde per Lane.
985, also sagen wir mal 1 Gigabyte. So ein bisschen weniger.
Pro Lane.
Pro Lane, genau so. Und die haben, genau, 16 Lanes, dann haben die maximal 16 Gigabyte die Sekunde. Und so Grafikkarten steckt man auch so rein, wenn die günstigste Lane, weil nicht alle Slots haben das ja komplett. Und dann hast du schon eine 16 Gigabyte. Da kannst du mir nicht erzählen, dass die Texturen da reinladen lange dauert.
Kannst du mir nicht erzählen, Alter.
Am Bus, ist deine Textur korrekt und direkt?
Also in meinem jetzigen, doch sehr alten Mac Pro dauert das dann schon.
Ja, aber das wird wahrscheinlich noch eine Menge andere Faktoren, die da eine Rolle spielen. Also das Programm, was die Textur lebt, die SSD, die das liefern muss, dann keine Ahnung, wenn die da in 1 Kilo Byte Chunks die Textur einlesen, ja dann ist natürlich, klar ist das langsam.
Und dann komprimiert die das glaube ich auch, ne? Die Grafikkarte, bevor sie das anzeigt, so. Oder die komprimiert das vorher und dann wird die übertragen, und dann wird die komprimiert, und dann passiert das glaube ich auch noch. Ja, aber wie gesagt, also die Karte so ein bisschen Baumeerbauchschmerzen, jetzt mittlerweile finde ich sie okay. Ich werde sicherlich dann auch wieder beim Mac bleiben, weil einfach das ganze, ja rundherum bei mir zu Hause wirklich viel, viel besser ist. In der Firma werde ich es weiterhin nicht empfehlen können. Weil da wäre ich auch oft gefragt, so Pipeline-Aufbau, etc. Da werde ich weiterhin sagen, bleib bei euren PCs, ihr seid da besser beraten, ihr habt euren CIS-Admin, der kümmert sich da drum, deswegen ist es nicht so schlimm mit dem ganzen Vian-Software, bla bla Updates. Und ja, und da könnt ihr halt die Grafikkarte, die auch gerade am besten für eure Spezialisierung ist. Also es ist ja auch bei diesem ganzen Benchmark, halt auch wenn man die Grafikkarten-Benchmark sich anguckt, es ist ja auch ganz klar, es gibt ja einige Grafikkarten, die sind mehr OpenCL-lastig, gut. Und dann gibt es einige Grafikkarten, die sind in Maya gut, dann gibt es einige Grafikkarten, die sind so in Mari gut, also in diesen Mari-Zibras-Sachen gut, weil sie irgendwie zwei Milliarden Polygonen anzeigen können schneller. Also sie haben alle so ihre Spezialisierung und so. Und das ist, vielleicht hat Apple jetzt hier so die Durchschnitts-Grafikkarte, die halt für überall so ein bisschen gut ist, gewählt. So, also Preis-Leistungs-, also gut heißt ja auch immer Preis-Leistung, weil du dann auch manchmal für 20 Artists sowas hinstellen musst. Da verfallen halt auch so 100, 200 Dollar so ein bisschen so ins Gewicht. Ja, ich finde es halt schade, dass sie nicht sich geöffnet haben und gesagt haben, ey komm steckt euch da rein, was ihr wollt. Ich finde das echt schade.
Naja, das war ja noch nie Apples Devise und da sind ja auch, sagen wir mal, also ich finde das ja irgendwie ganz interessant, diese Idee mit dieser Energiekapsel, die du auf den Tisch stellst. Und die ja dann auch, weil du dich nicht mehr so sehr an diese eingebaute Peripherie bindest, ja also du hast sozusagen eigentlich nur noch so ein CPU-Würfel und GPU-Würfel, die du dann in der Zukunft auch leichter tauschen kannst. Also wenn du sozusagen die Gier nach mehr Gerät hast, dann steckst du dir da nicht eine neue Karte rein, sondern dann kaufst du dir einfach den Mac Pro des Jahres, der dann nochmal ein paar Cores mehr hat in der CPU und wo dann halt die Grafikkarte nochmal sich selbst übertrifft. Und das alte Teil kommt auf eBay und du weißt, was die Dinger für einen Wiederverkaufswert haben, dass man nämlich, wenn man da eigentlich erstmal da drin ist in diesem Zyklus, so viel gar nicht mehr zahlen muss für diese Geräte.
Ja, aber das Problem ist halt dieser Unterschied zwischen CPU und GPU-Erneuerung, also der Zyklus ist halt mittlerweile total unterschiedlich geworden. Das ist halt das Hauptproblem.
Aber wenn du halt mehr Cores kriegst, auch wenn die Cores selber nicht schneller werden?
Aber wie lange hat es jetzt gedauert, dass Intel mal mit einem neuen Xeons rauskam? Das war jetzt wirklich zwei, drei Jahre, oder?
Ja, aber Xeons ist ja wieder eine andere Liga. Da ist der Takt halt ein bisschen langsamer.
Ja, da sind aber Xeons hier drin. Und mein Mac Pro ist noch Xeons.
Ja, aber bei den anderen Geräten, hier sind keine Xeons.
Ach so, hier nicht.
Da geht der Takt ein bisschen schneller.
Genau, aber bei den großen Grafikkarten gefühlt alle drei Monate eine komplett neue Serie raus.
Nee, eigentlich einmal im Jahr. Also klar, die remodeln immer und machen ihre Namen dann komplett neu, aber meistens sind es die Grafikkarten. Also bei AMD kenne ich mich jetzt gerade noch, diese neuen Serien, nur die 92 und ich glaube, die 92X haben diese neue CPU, was richtig neu ist und noch die 280 ist eigentlich eine 7970 vom letzten Jahr, nur remodelt und ein bisschen Takt angehoben und Zeug und so, aber ist der Chip vom letzten Jahr und die kleineren Karten, ja weiß nicht, ob bei den ganz kleinen Karten sogar noch der Chip von vor zwei Jahren drin ist, also die remodeln einfach nur jedes Jahr damit irgendwie die Kunden da denken, ist alles geil und neu, aber ist gar nicht der Fall.
Ja, aber ist nicht, nicht, also so greingefühlsmäßig dachte ich, dass es so doppelt so.
Schnell wie Prozessor im Moment so. Na doch, letztes Jahr Ivy Bridge, jetzt hier Haswell, vorletztes Jahr Sandy Bridge, so das haut schon hin.
Ah, die kommen alle gefühlt.
Okay, also wir halten fest, der Mac Pro ist jetzt kein Wellenbrecher. Final Cut Pro X ist eher iMovie für Fortgeschrittene.
Die sind wirklich alle ausgestiegen.
Alle.
Und was sagt Apple dazu? Das müssen die doch irgendwie merken und können die nicht zurückgrudern? Ich meine, Git rollback, zack.
Das ist vielleicht wurschtig.
Das war halt ein großer Aufschrei. Also es war wirklich so, also alle, man, es war halt ein geiles Programm und das hat halt viel getan. Das war so die Red Epic in der Software-Branche, also weil es gab halt nur Avid. Punkt.
Das müssen die doch spüren, wenn plötzlich alle abhauen. Das muss doch bei, also die lassen auch so ein Produkt nicht fallen. Da muss man noch nicht überlegen, geht man da zurück, rudert man um oder so, weiß schon. Wundert mich ein bisschen. Da sind doch Köpfe gerollt bei Apple, oder?
Da sind Köpfe gerollt, bin ich sicher.
Naja, also es sind auf jeden Fall Strategien geändert worden.
Aber noch sieht man davon nichts.
Doch.
Bei Final Cut?
Nee, aber bei Logic.
Ist da der gleiche Unfall passiert?
Da ist ihnen das nicht passiert.
Logic X ist extrem seamless, da schreit keiner. Und da...
Wann kam dieses Final Cut X und wann kam das Logic Update, ist da also die Zeit?
Logic ist jetzt erst passiert, sowohl bei MWR oder so.
Und Logic vor schon Final Cut, wann war das?
Aber sie machen es doch schon wieder. Guck dir doch den Aufschrei an, hier mit dem iWork-Gwatsch, was alle geschehen haben, sei es Keynote, sei es Numbers, sei es Pages.
Okay, also iWork und die Pro-Linie, das sind schon nochmal so zwei ganz unterschiedliche Sachen.
Ist klar, aber sie treten trotzdem immer wieder auf dieselbe Mine drauf, irgendwelche Updates zu machen, wo sie Funktionalitäten rausnehmen, wo die User sich alle fragen, what the fuck?
Auch ich glaube, dass sie letzten Endes mit ihrem Final Cut Pro X wahrscheinlich gar nicht mal so schlecht gefahren sind, weil sie einfach ganz andere Skalierungseffekte haben. Also die paar Schrei-Hälse im Super-Pro-Bereich einzutauschen gegen viele tausende neue Kunden, die einfach so das Upgrade von einem iMovie mitnehmen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das so viele mitnehmen, weil du kriegst halt einfach dieses Premiere mit in dieser CS-Shoot mit, umsonst geliefert.
CS-Shoot ist ja auch nicht gerade das, was du dir mal eben so kaufst, weil das ja nun auch wirklich so die Eisenkette ist.
Kennst du viele? Wie viele Leute kennst du?
Ich kenne mehr Leute, die privaten Final Cut sich kaufen als die Creative.
Aber die haben dann trotzdem die Creative-Sit?
Nein, ich kenne definitiv viele Leute, die sich Final Cut... Also Filmer, Leute, die Doku, ich kenne nur so Doku-Film-Leute und so weiter, das ist durchaus die auch die ganzen Leute, die halt jetzt so, ich sag mal, es soll jetzt nicht abfällig klingen, aber so YouTube und Vimeo-Videos und so selber produzieren, die holen sich halt alle sowas. Weil der Preispunkt ist halt für die natürlich irgendwie super attraktiv, also 250 Euro kostet und das Premiere kriegst du halt nur mit der Creative Suite und dann zahlst du minimal 1000 Euro oder sowas oder mietest das im Cloud, was auch immer, ein Rentelangebot. Von daher, wenn ihr zum Beispiel Adobe sagen wollt, ok Premiere gibt es jetzt auch einzeln für 250 oder 500, dann wäre das vielleicht nochmal ein Ding mehr, aber ich hab gerade gesehen, das gibt es nur in der Creative Suite. Von daher, also ich kenn auf jeden Fall schon extrem viele Leute, die jetzt Final Cut benutzen, die vorher, wo Final Cut einfach vom Interface viel zu komplex waren, vom Preispunkt auf einfach astronomisch für die sozusagen. Das ist halt eher, wie gesagt, so ein etwas anspruchsvolleres iMovie. Und ich könnte mir halt vorstellen, dass Apple halt auch eben sagt, ok ist jetzt schön und gut, wenn da die Pappnasen im Super Pro Bereich jetzt halt irgendwie Avid benutzen sollen, sich doch da irgendwie ärgern, wir kriegen jetzt dafür irgendwie Größenordnung 10 oder 100 mal mehr User, die irgendwie ihre eigenen Videos damit produzieren jetzt, und dann ist auch gut. Ich weiß nicht, inwiefern das denen was bringt überhaupt, wenn sie sich damit schüten können.
Es bringt denen halt Prestige halt auch. Sie haben die Pro User wirklich zum großen Teil halt wirklich verloren. Also und da auch, also es sah halt teilweise, sie haben jetzt wirklich im letzten Moment diesen Stecker gezogen, deswegen haben die auch den Pro so früh angekündigt, weil die Leute den wirklich auch hardwaremäßig weggerannt sind dadurch. Weil warum musst du dir dann noch einen Mac hinstellen, wenn du nicht mehr auch die Software und so weiter da drauf hast? Also ich kenne diese Gespräche, ich saß mit Leuten, die genau so gedacht haben. Warum stellen wir jetzt nicht den PC hin? Warum? Also weshalb?
Du meinst, es ist nicht nur Final Cut weggebrochen, sondern die Hardware gleich mit?
Ja genau, deswegen mussten sie auch diesen Mac Pro so früh ankündigen, weil die Leute sind ihnen weggerannt, also wirklich so in Scharen. Weil es ist ja auch mit diesem Windows, wie man mal Mühe gehalten, was man davon will, aber diese neuen Windows-Versionen sind jetzt nicht mehr von der Usability so weit weg von der Mac. Ich muss halt diesen Switch immer machen, also fast täglich. Da sind halt einige Sachen, die sind noch nicht so schön, aber es ist halt auch ein Betriebssystem, das benutzbar ist.
Am Ende verbringst du halt auch 95 Prozent der Zeit in deiner Anwendung und gerade diese Pro-Apps sind ja das Betriebssystem eh weitgehend aus, von daher sieht das irgendwie an der Stelle keiner. Naja, das ist auch nachvollziehbar. Ja, das ist sicherlich der eine Grund. Der andere Grund ist, glaube ich auch, dass sie natürlich, deswegen haben sie es wahrscheinlich auch zur WWDC getimed, dass sie auch die Developer einschwören wollen auf ihr neues Konzept. Und da bin ich halt immer noch, das ist für mich immer noch die große Frage, ob das so ausgeht. Leute, jetzt ist Weihnachten, es gibt Geschenke. Genau, ich wollte mal hier so ein bisschen den Gabentisch aufmachen hier, mein neuer Mac Pro irgendwie, Donkey Edition, auch ganz großes Kino, ja, also. Wir grinsen alle. Was habe ich hier? Ich habe ja ein Kinder Macbook Pro, so zum Aufklappen aus Holz.
Wir sollen jetzt noch so einen Fotostream live machen damit, weil ihr Fotos machen könnt und die Leute sehen.
Tritt mal den User noch nach dem Munde, das verlangen die seit Jahren, dass wir hier Live-Streaming machen.
Ja, gibt es übrigens auch als iPad, so, das ist jetzt die normale Variante. Nein, aber es gibt auch ein iPhone. Ist das nicht super? Das kann ich echt jedem nur empfehlen, irgendwie so der gemeine Nerd. Wovon rede ich? Ich rede von Donkey. Das iPhone heißt...
Ist aber noch ein iPhone 4, ne? Hat den Kopfhörer oben.
iWoodie, genau. Ja, verstehe. Ein iPhone 4. Also, ich rede jetzt von einem Holz, in Holz nachgeschnitzten iPhone, wo der Screen einfach Tafeloberfläche ist und du kannst mit Kreide drauf malen. Das ist großartig.
Passen da auch die iPhone 4 Bumper?
Keine Ahnung. Hab ich nicht ausprobiert. Können wir aber mal ausprobieren. Das ist hier das Macbook, das heißt iWood.
Ziemlich perfekt. Ganz minimal anders, aber so eine Gummihülle sollte gehen. Ganz schön schwer so für die Auflösung.
Für den Hipster, der jetzt unerwartet Nachwuchs bekommen hat, ist das auf jeden Fall eine Empfehlung für Weihnachten.
Im Grenzlauer Berg laufen ja sogar die Kinder in die Seiner Klamotten rum, hab ich gesehen.
Holzspielzeug in modern.
Letztens hab ich einen an der Schule gesehen, der war geschätzte 10 oder 11, und der hat telefoniert und ich hörte nur noch, du siehst mich in Maps und dann holst du mich ab. Wirklich.
Was denn dann?
Du siehst mich in Maps und dann holst du mich ab. Also der meint wahrscheinlich find friends, aber... Genau.
Ich benutze das ja sehr gerne. Ich war heute im Apple Store übrigens noch, ich hab mich mal auf die Date entstanden. Ein Erlebnis? Ne, nicht impognito. Ganz im Gegenteil, ich war auffällig.
Verhaltensauffällig. My name is Tim.
Ich wollte den Gewichtsvergleich machen zwischen dem iPad und dem iPad Mini. Das Problem ist, dass sie die halt einerseits auf zwei verschiedenen Tischen haben. Also es gibt halt einen Tisch mit iPad und einen Tisch mit iPad Mini. Und nicht nebeneinander die Dinger. Und sie sind ja auch alle noch angekettet wegen Alarm-Klaus-Schutz und so weiter. Das heißt, ich musste mich so zwischen die beiden Tische stellen, nach links und rechts, genau, und dann irgendwie versuchen, da einen Vergleich zu machen. Aber das war alles bogus. Was mir aufgefallen ist, ist, dass dieses iPad Air wirklich leicht rüberkommt. Also es hat so diese Schwere verloren, die so die letzten Geräte so hatten. Das ist wirklich nicht Helium gefüllt, ja. Ja, jetzt weiß ich nicht. Ich dachte ja, wenn dieses Mini Air-Dingsretina rauskommt, dann kauf ich mir das. Und? Das Problem ist, dass ich eigentlich mit dem iPad eigentlich nix anfangen kann.
Deswegen hast du hier so viele iPad-Uren, weil wir ja nix zu tun haben.
Naja, ich mein so als Touch-Control hier.
Du könntest wenigstens ein iPad auf Bitcoin stellen, dann müsste ich ja nicht andauernd mein Telefon leer saugen. Oder beides gleichzeitig, ich meine, da ist genug Platz für Uhr und Bitcoins. Und Wetter und Temperatur und Shit.
Ja, guck mal, ich mach hier mal auf mein iPhone. Dann mach ich das an, wir sind schon bei 327 Euro.
Meine Fresse.
Ja, aber warum musst du das jetzt so in realtime wissen? Den verkaufst du eigentlich.
Damit er weiß, wann er rausrennt.
Dann denk ich, dass du hier einfach so hin damit du froh bist.
Verstehe. Geht auch dann nicht aus, hast du gemerkt? Die App geht, also dann geht das Telefon nicht mehr aus, der verhindert das.
Wenn Strom dran ist, ne?
Ja, weil er im Hintergrund meint.
Ja, jeder Mikroflop zählt.
Ja, wobei dieses Mini, ich meine, wenn, dann kauft man sich das natürlich in der rechts unten Ausstattung und dann kostet das Ding halt irgendwie einen Tausender. Was? Naja, kostet runter, warte mal.
100 Euro unter dem iPhone. Wobei dann auch die Leute wieder gefragt haben, warum ist denn eigentlich der iPhone teurer?
Machen wir doch mal hier den, ich mach das hier mal onscreen hier.
Auf den Schirm.
Auf den Schirm. So, dann kaufe ich hier irgendwie einmal iPad Mini.
Geht bei 389 los.
Dann will man da ein Cellular drin haben, weil sonst ist es irgendwie...
Das kostet dann schon 509 und du hast noch 16 Gb nur.
Genau, dann willst du 128 GB haben, weil wenn du schon 90 Euro aufpreist, dann willst du auch den maximalen Lampen...
Dann musst du dann dreimal 90 Euro drauflegen, was 270 Euro macht.
Dann bist du bei 779 Euro.
Das sind aber nicht fast 1000, sondern fast 800.
Wir sind ja auch noch nicht fertig, mein Freund.
Ach so, jetzt geht's. Und die Hülle, das Kabel, Kopfhörer...
Die Laser-Gravur ist kostenlos. Die überspringen wir jetzt mal. So, dann will ich natürlich einen Smart-Case haben.
Und natürlich in Leder?
Das gibt's nur in Leder.
Na da drüber, das billige für 39, oder?
Ach, dieses Smart-Cover, diesen Quatsch. Nee, so ein Scheiß kommt mir da nicht drauf. Das schützt ja nicht, ich meine, das liegt ja nur drauf und stört. Ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, was die Leute haben an diesem Cover. Dieses Case ist wirklich das Einzige, was sinnvoll ist.
Aber wo ist denn der Unterschied zwischen Case... Ach so, Case ist noch so ein unten drunter Ding und Cover ist nur oben. Man kann es ja schlecht erkennen an deren Zeichnung.
Ja, ja, dieses Cover ist auch nur so magnetisch rangepflanscht und es hat jetzt auch nicht so diese automatische Zentrierung. Das haben sie irgendwie... Nee, nee, nee, ich habe da wieder rumgespielt, da kannst du das irgendwie 3, 4 cm hoch und runter machen.
Das ist ja auch innen drin so bearbeitet, dass du es mit deinem Display abwischen kannst.
Anyway, ich finde das pointless, weil wenn ich das Teil da drauf mache und ich schiebe das dann in eine Tasche, das ist für mich der Moment, wo so ein Cover seinen Sinn entfaltet, dann schiebst du halt dieses Cover einfach herunter, weil es ist ja dann nur magnetisch drangeplatscht.
Ja, also bei meinem iPad 3 war die Cover, geht das. Ich habe so einen Cover an meinem iPad 3.
Das ist das Alte, das ist jetzt das Neue, da haben sie es anders gemacht.
Ja, nee, das ist noch weniger.
Da ist das Metall irgendwie nicht mehr außen und so, da ist der Schnapper irgendwie anders.
Ja gut, der zerkratzt nicht mehr, das ist halt in dieses Polyuritan eingeführt.
Urinat, Polyurinat.
Nein, aber es ist halt so, wenn du es halt in eine enge Tasche reinschiebst, dann schiebst du halt dieses Cover weg. Das ist für mich einfach bekloppt. So, jetzt haben wir hier 69 Euro, jetzt bin ich bei 847,99.
Oh, wie viel wiegt so ein Cover? Da kannst du ja gleich wieder normale Trophen. Dann bist du bei 947.
Du brauchst noch zusätzliche Lightning-Kabel, also der Tausender ist voll.
Ja, ja, also gefühlt kostet ein Tausend.
Aber ob du dann wirklich 128 GB Storage brauchst?
Warum kaufst du keinen iPod, so einen kleinen, mit Platte noch?
Naja, weil der halt keinen 8 Zoll Bildschirm hat.
Brauchst du da bei Podcasts überhaupt nichts?
Nein, es geht ja auch nicht um Podcasts, es geht um Filme. Für Podcasts habe ich einen iPhone.
Gibt es 1,8 Zoll SSDs? Das heißt, man könnte... Ach so, die iPods haben aber... Haben die Sata?
Die haben noch Compact Flash Anschluss.
Und haben die 1,8 SSD-Dinger?
Compact Flash bestimmt.
Boah, das ist mein SSD.
Pimp my iPod.
Mit einer 500 Gigabyte SSD.
Du willst ja jetzt Filme drauf machen, weil du denn die auf Reisen deinen Kindern vor die Nase klatschst, damit die dich nicht nerven, oder was? Weil ich gucke ja auch Filme auf meinem iPad, aber in der Regel gucke ich sie da, wo ich jetzt selber stabil bin. Also stabil heißt jetzt nicht im Auto fahren oder sonst wo.
Das ist zum Beispiel eine Anwendung.
Ja, aber dann streame ich die einfach.
Genau, vom Server.
Ich gucke die eben bloß einmal. Was soll ich so herunterladen?
Im Zug?
Ja, deswegen sage ich ja da, wo ich stabil bin, wenn ich irgendwo zu Hause bin oder in einem Hotel.
Wenn ich stabil bin, dann brauche ich gar kein iPad.
Und du willst ja mal alle Filme auf dem...
Den kannst du im Zug nicht benutzen, dein Mac.
Doch, aber das iPad, also das iPad wiederum, ich habe ja kein iPad, weil ich mir denke, mein Gott, ich habe ein 11 Zoll R, was soll ich ein scheiß iPad haben? Aber das iPad Mini ist halt, das geht halt noch in meine kleine Tasche mit rein, die ich hier so einfach am Gürtel trage. Das ist so der Universal Browser to go. So, das schiebt man da halt rein. Ich habe es halt ausprobiert. Ich habe extra noch diese Apple Sklaven genötigt, dieses Caster auszupacken.
Das gehört zu deinem modischen Herrendesign der 80er.
Weil das wird natürlich nicht präsentiert, die wirklich wichtigen Produkte stehen da wieder nicht. Und es passt halt hier in diese Tasche rein. Das heißt, ich muss noch nicht mal drüber nachdenken. Ich habe es halt einfach dabei. Wenn man jetzt hier irgendwie irgendwo hinfährt und man will jetzt nicht The Full Monty, The Full Gear haben.
Aber wie viele Filme willst du da drauf machen? Selbst das kleinste Modell passen drei Filme drauf. Das ist doch reichen.
Nee, das reicht nicht.
Na gut, dann nimmst du jetzt das zweitgrößte Modell.
Weil du weißt, wie schnell die Kinder langweilig ist.
Es geht nicht nur um die Kinder, es geht natürlich auch um mich. Ich würde alle Filme drauf machen, die ich schon immer mal gucken wollte, wo ich aber nie zukomme. Und wenn ich dann in dem Moment bin, und das ist immer einer ohne Internet, ohne WLAN, und wo entweder fängt der Film jetzt an oder hat keinen Sinn.
Also in Wieserland-Deutschland kannst du da nicht noch eine billige Festplatte.
Das heißt, bei Timme werden Zeiten, wo er offline ist, mit Filmen abgedeckt.
Und da kann er keine Festplatte oder irgendeine Flashkarte noch rausholen.
Wozu denn, wenn da 128 GB in diesem Scheißteil drin sind?
Um ein kleines Modell zu nehmen und dann...
Pappalapapp, das ist doch wirklich Quatsch. Ich meine, also entweder macht man das oder nicht.
Also für die 90 Euro, die du da pro Verdopplung bezahlst, würdest du schon eine Terabyte-Platte kriegen.
Jedes 90 Euro kauft ihr nochmal doppelt so viel wie das 90 Euro davor.
Ja, aber insgesamt zahlst du 270 Euro extra. Für die 270 Euro kannst du den Festplatten-Rate mitschleppen. Den 2,5 Zoll.
Dennis, das ist Apple. Man kauft ein Apple-Produkt nicht mit so einer Windows-Logik.
Ja, aber ich hätte auch keinen Bock, 1000 Euro für einen Mini-Fernseher auszugeben.
Ja, ich auch nicht. Deswegen sage ich mir halt so, eigentlich ist mir das jetzt noch zu teuer. Aber ich kann halt kein anderes Gerät kaufen als das, weil das ist halt das Einzige, was geht. Ich kaufe mir nicht eins ohne 3G und ich kaufe mir auch nicht eins mit weniger Speicher, wenn es eins gibt, was mehr hat.
Und eins mit Android schon gar nicht.
Tja, das ist doch am Arsch.
Nee, ach du meine Android, ich bitte dich.
Ich habe ja letztens auch mein Android. Ich habe ja noch so ein ganz kleines, altes Android. Ich habe ja noch nie ein iPhone besessen. Ich habe noch nie ein iOS-Gerät besessen, muss ich dazu sagen.
Wow, einer der unberührten.
Ja, weil es wirklich so ein Xperia Active Sony, so ein mini kleines Ding ist. Ich bin eigentlich relativ happy gewesen, aber es war halt irgendwie mit dem 4.0 Update Android, also offizielles Sony 4.0 Update Android, hat das komplette Telefon kaputt gemacht. Ich habe mir letzte Woche wirklich mal die Zeit genommen und da mal so eine Stunde mit verbracht und so einen Cyanogen-Mod drauf gespielt, mit dem neuesten Android drauf. Und dieses Telefon ist auf einmal absolut benutzbar. Es ist einfach die totale helle Freude. Es ist schnell, es ist responsive, du kannst wirklich 1000 Sachen installieren. Aber was ist das Android? Das ist Android 4.3, also Usability. Ich habe auch öfter mal ein iPhone in der Hand.
Mit welchem OS ist denn das ausgeliefert worden? Noch mit irgendeinem 2X? Da kannst du dann 4.3 noch drauf fahren.
Und es ist schneller als das 2X immer. Also das ist jetzt hier nur Genmode. Die Batterie hält länger. Ich habe fast mit dem Ding fast 36 Stunden Batterie mit Benutzung.
36 Stunden mit Benutzung von was? Vom Calculator?
Nein, ich fahre auf Bahn, weil ich wohne ja ein bisschen außerhalb.
Du wolltest mir nicht sagen, dass du 36 Stunden lang auf diesem Ding surfst?
Nein, aber schon so mit 2 Stunden Bahnfahrt am Tag mit drinne, wo ich immer das Ding anhabe und Twitter anhabe.
Ist das auch so ein Monsterscreen?
Das ist so ein ganz kleines. Wollte ich noch mal in die Runde beffen, weil es ja dass sie alle äppeln und so?
Ne, ne, ne, ne. Ich habe auch ein Android Phone.
Komisch, den Apple drauf hinten.
Ich habe nie gesagt, dass ich exklusiv sowas habe.
Ich habe auch ein Android-Device hier. Das steht hier immer rum und zeigt...
Ich benutze das immer, wenn ich im Ausland bin.
Also die Uhr geht gut hier.
Dann darf ich auf meine deutschen SIM-Karten aufpassen und dann...
Das ist furchtbar, oder? Ich nehme das immer in die Hand. Nein, wenn ich das da reinstecke, ist das eine Uhr. Und dann, wenn man halt dieses Nexus 7 irgendwie anfasst, dann sieht es halt so aus. Das ist nicht schön? Nicht schön?
Dann mach dir einen anderen Hintergrund, wenn dir das nicht gefällt.
Das geht auch nicht um den Hintergrund. Ich guck dir mal diese Eigenschaft, diese ganze Aufteilung an. Ich breche ins Essen, das ist furchtbar. Das geht nicht.
Da ist der iOS 7 sogar noch hübscher.
Na ja, kommen wir nicht mit iOS 7.
Also du meinst, ich sollte mal ein Cyano geben?
Ja, probier das mal. Das hat wirklich mein Telefon einfach mal... Also das war wie ein Fond.
Reanimiert.
Reanimiert. Ich bin glücklich. Also ich warte halt immer noch auf einen würdigen Nachfolger dafür.
Wir sollen mal Android für eine 63-CI machen.
Ich hab gerade eben meinen Klick, dein Ding, weil du sagst, das ist ja Sony Ericsson. Tralala ist ja nicht in der Liste der offiziell supporteten Devices. Das heißt also die Liste der Devices, wo es drauf geht, ist wesentlich größer als das, was hier an der offiziellen Liste steht.
Die haben schon einen Grund, warum wir da gerade eine Firma draus gemacht haben, weil lief wohl ganz gut.
Also die Geschwindigkeit aus diesem Telefon, das ist ja nur ein Gigahertz.
Das kannst du schon seit Jahren sehen, wenn du zum Beispiel uralte Macs nimmst, weißt du, noch so mit Power-PC und so ein Scheiß, und dann denkst du, ich schnarche und irgendwann denkst du, schmeiß ich ihn jetzt weg oder mach ich einen Linux drauf oder mach ich einen BSD drauf?
Power-PC war gar nicht so schlecht.
Ja, aber es ist trotzdem interessant, wenn man weniger als mehr... Das war auch einer der Punkte, die ich für heute aufgeschrieben habe. Ich hab jetzt hier mal ein bisschen mit Mavericks rumgespielt auf dem anderen Rechner und musste dann auch so diverse Sachen wie Quatsch-Codex, die ich vor Jahren mal gekauft habe. Es gibt so ein WMV-Codex, so für Sekunde. Ein Video-Codex und dann sagt der, damit das hier läuft, brauchst du ein Update und dann lädt der für einen verdammten Video-Codex 100 Megabyte runter. 100 Megabyte. Und dann denkst du so, Flipform-Mac, ist so ein WMV-Troll, aber trotzdem...
Ich muss mir auch mal hinstellen, diese Stühle, die machen mich fertig auf.
Weil da gleich diese Silver-Stream oder diese Windows-Strikes beiher sind.
Aber trotzdem, was die alle für eine Scheiße mit sich rumschleppen. Das kann ich mir schon vorstellen.
Bequemer.
Du musst die Stühle höher machen, wenn du da schlecht drauf sitzt.
Ne, das fragmentiert meine Gesäßemuskulär.
Das ist ein Stuhl, der dich bewegen soll.
Kann man nicht höher stellen. Er wollte den eigentlich schon wegschmeißen, als du noch nicht da warst. Und hat gesagt, wenn du den wegschmeißt, dann kommst du nicht mehr.
Genau. Auf den kann ich echt nicht lange sitzen.
Aber wir könnten aber...
Jetzt ist ja auch schon hier ein paar Stunden rum. Da muss man ab und zu mal seine Arschbacke wechseln.
Die Arschbacke wechseln.
Du hast die Arschbacke gewechselt, mein Michael. So, was war denn jetzt hier mit Mavericks? Nach dem 1000-Euro-iPad?
Na, na. Na, ich bin ja totaler Mavericks-Fanboy. Bin ich geworden. Bis auf darauf, dass hier natürlich mein ganzes Audio-Scheiß zusammengebrochen ist. Aber das liegt ja wahrscheinlich dann eher an der Audio-Scheiße.
Na, also es gibt einen Bug, den kann ich ja zumindest mal kurz reinschneiden, weil ich bin ja auch totaler Mavericks-Freund eigentlich. Aber mein Firewire-Audio-Interface, und das ist nicht nur meins, sorgt dafür, dass Quicktime, der Quicktime-Player, und auch Videos, die im Browser so abspülen, YouTube-Videos, die halt HTML5 oder so benutzen, die machen dann so Knistern auf dem Audio-Kanal. iTunes geht, kein Problem, Video-Audio super. VLC, M-Player, alle super über das Firewire-Audio-Interface, aber Quicktime-Player und im Safari, HTML5-Video macht so......ungefähr so. Und habe ich buggefeilt und meinten so, ja, das Duplicate haben wir schon ein paar Mal bekommen und gucken wir uns mal an. Also das ist eigentlich so mein einer Grief, oder mein ein Problem, und dann das andere mit Mavericks, das war noch, eins war noch irgendwie ein bisschen ätzend.
Na, der geht halt schlafen, obwohl man da das Ding gemautet hat, habe ich ja letztens ja schon erzählt. Dann mein Feindein ist immer noch irgendwie komisch, aber ich hoffe mal, bei dem nächsten Update ist das alles bedingt.
Und was halt auch ein bisschen nervig ist, so ich habe so ein paar Apps, die sich darauf verlassen, dass, also die jetzt sozusagen weg priorisiert werden von AppNap, weil die sind nicht im Hintergrund, die lasse ich im Hintergrund laufen. Zum Beispiel meine Lieblings-App, um Tee zu teimen, ja, so ein ganz kleines Programm, was so ein Typ schon seit Ewigkeiten immer mal wieder auch updatet. Kupa, das macht wirklich nichts mehr als so ein paar Tee-Presets und wählt man anderen, weil ich mag das total gern. Da habe ich dann auch einen App Store für iOS schon gekauft, um ihn so ein bisschen zu supporten. Und durch dieses AppNap, weil die ja im Hintergrund timet, bleibt halt der Timer dann stehen, weil einfach weggeschedielt wird, er hat jetzt schon ein Update rausgeschoben.
Hat es aber ausschalten müssen.
Und man kann es ausschalten, genau, das habe ich alles darüber, durch dieses Problem mit dem Tee-Timer, herausgefunden. Und ich habe so ein paar andere Programme auch noch gehabt, wo ich damit ein bisschen auf die Fresse geblumme.
Also ausschalten ist mit Abfallinfo irgendwie, und dann sagt man hier AppNap nicht und so. Weil ich habe irgendeine App, das auch im Hintergrund Zeug machen sollte, und dann gehe ich nach Stunden wieder in irgendwie Download oder irgendwie sowas, gehe ich nach Stunden lang hin, und dann hat das Ding einfach aufgehört, irgendwo seinen Job zu machen. Und dann alles klar, Abfallinfo, AppNap, ausschalten, fertig.
Und ich finde halt, das ist natürlich an sich ein schönes Feature, aber irgendwie hätten sie dann vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen transparenter für den User, mal gleich so beim Start hier, pass mal auf, der Bitcoin-Dings war es.
Der hört auf, im Hintergrund seine Blockchains zu updaten.
Ach du Scheiße.
Der wird einfach dann auch weggeslept.
Aber das mit dem Audio nervt mich eigentlich gerade ein bisschen mehr.
Okay, ich finde ja interessant, dass du auch Knisterproblematiken hast. Ich habe nämlich auch Knisterproblematiken. Und das ist beim Abspielen mit dem QuickTime-Player.
Und wie gesagt im Browser, also im Safari. Aber hast du, du hast ja kein Firewire, du machst ja über Ethernet auch.
Ja, und da tauchen halt jetzt das erste Mal seit drei Jahren Probleme auf. Und was du jetzt sagst, lässt mich so ein bisschen gerade grübeln, ob das Problem nicht vielleicht schon vorher entsteht und gar nicht so sehr jetzt an dem Dante selber liegt.
Und was halt auch interessant ist, wenn ich den QuickTime-Player benutze und dann ein Video abspiele, dann ist es auch manchmal so, dass das Video ruckelt. Also perfekt, super Video fängt an zu ruckeln, aber das Audio bleibt dann knisterfrei. Und wenn es knistert, ist es andersrum. Das Video spielt flüssig ab, aber... Wie gesagt, iTunes kann es ja perfekt abspielen, ja. Das Video auch und VLC und M-Player und alle sowieso. Aber irgendwie scheint es da in so irgendeinem Subsystem so ganz funky, vielleicht auch Priorisierungsprobleme zu geben mit dem Firewire-Driver oder was auch immer. Da ist ein bisschen was im Argen.
Ich habe da diesen obskuren Audio-Bug, den ich hier mit dem USB-Interfacer, das ich letztes Mal angesprochen habe, ein bisschen analysiert. Und da haut mir irgendwas im Zehn-Milli-Sekunden-Takt das Audio weg. Also wenn man sich das Audio mal so richtig schön visualisiert. Roddi hat mir da ein bisschen geholfen. Dann sieht man so richtig, dass so in Zehn-Milli-Sekunden-Abständen immer so eine Milli Sekunde ausgelöscht wird. Also so richtig leer. Und das führt natürlich dann zu diesen Problemen. Warum das so ist, weiß ich nicht. Ich habe es aber mittlerweile reduzieren können auf das...
Auf 15...
.Audio-Subsystem. Ich kann nicht sagen, das Gerät oder der Treiber oder Core Audio, wenn er damit spricht oder so.
Aber feil mal alles schön immer bei Apple ein, damit die da...
Ja, aber das sind so obskure Probleme. Ich kann die überhaupt gar nicht... Ich wüsste nicht, was ich da hinschreiben soll, wie sie das reproduzieren sollen.
Ja, aber es reicht ja schon, zumindest auch, wenn Leute da ganz viel Alarm machen, dass sie überhaupt mal vielleicht selber gucken. Wenn halt keiner was sagt.
Ja, da hast du natürlich recht. Ich rede jetzt vor allem hier so mit den ganzen anderen Support-Abteilungen.
Ja, aber ansonsten war dieses Mavericks-Upgrade auch echt das smootheste Upgrade, was ich jemals eigentlich so bei Mac OS hatte. Also das war so dieses... Gut, ich hab's auch in der Firma installiert. Wir haben zweimal einen Gigabit-Downlink. Und ich hab auf den Button geklickt und hab, glaube ich, mit 40 Megabyte die Sekunde dieses Mavericks-Update gezogen. Also es war schon so richtig so...
It's ready.
It's ready und dann, ja, also dieser ganze Installationsvorgang, der war so schnell und smooth. Und es kam hoch und meine Fenster waren da. Schön für dich, bei mir nicht. Ja, ich weiß, es gab auch, wie immer, ich hab auch einen Kollegen, also einen Freund von mir, der hat mich auch gefragt und war alles smooth und ich meinte, ein Traum, ja. Und er installiert das, das Ding bleibt beim Reboot hängen und er muss irgendwie nochmal clean installen. Aber das ist halt immer so...
Das war mein erstes glitches Betriebssystem-Update ever beim Echo SX.
Ich musste auch dreimal installieren, ich hatte noch ein GM, Roddi gibt mir das Richtige, ich installiere. Habe ich immer noch das GM und konnte nicht mehr updaten, weil er meinte, ich muss das Passwort von Roddi eingeben. Toll. Also zu Hause auf einem anderen Rechner das Richtige runtergeladen, hier auf den Laptop geschoben, installiert und dann hatte ich erst das Richtige, diese 603 und nicht mehr die 598 und auch wieder mit meinem Passwort.
Ja pff, lass mich doch hier mal ein bisschen annehmen.
Nein, ich konnte aber lokal ohne Fremdhilfe nicht updaten. Das heißt, es gab keinen Weg, um einen GM irgendwie auf den neuesten Stand zu kriegen.
Bei mir ist er ganz hinten, also er hat wirklich durchinstalliert und dann blieb halt der Balken ganz hinten stehen und es passierte nichts so.
Ja doch, aber du musst einfach zwei Stunden warten oder so.
Zwei Stunden warten habe ich nicht gemacht, halt neu gestartet, ging nicht. Es ist aber nicht in meinen User gebootet, dann hat er sich einen neuen User angelegt, dann habe ich das halt nochmal gemacht. Ich habe auch den User auf der anderen Partition. Also meinen richtigen User auf einer anderen Partition, dann habe ich ihn nochmal neu verlinkt und so, dann habe ich noch dreimal neu gebooten müssen und jetzt geht's. Und es ist sehr, sehr glitchfrei, aber ich weiß nicht, was da passiert ist.
Aber du hättest warten müssen. Ich habe gesagt, nee, ich habe hier ins Log geguckt und da sah alles gut aus, keine Fehler, und so habe ich ihn einfach machen lassen. Obwohl ich auch eine SSD habe, ich weiß nicht, was der so lange gebraucht hat.
Hat euch gleich noch einen neuen Account im NSA...
Er hat irgendwas hochgeladen, solange es dauerte.
Am Ende, ne?
Upload ist ja so dünn in Deutschland.
Am Ende, ja.
Ja, das hatte ich auch. Aber bei mir war es wirklich...
Dauert noch eine Sekunde. Ist klar.
Aber ich habe dann nicht halbe Stunde gewartet.
Aber okay, vielleicht ging es ja bei mir wirklich so schnell, weil ich an einer Dual-Gigabit-Leitung gehangen habe. Dann war auch der Upload viel schneller.
Ich habe das Gefühl, Sie hatten dann einen Fehler im Installer, der in manchen Konfigurationen am Schluss so eine komische, also nicht eine Loop, aber irgendwie so eine Warte. Also er wartet da auf Godot und Godot kommt nicht und irgendwann timet dann auch der letzte, also irgendeinen Timeout falsch gesetzt. Irgendwie sowas. Und wenn man dann den Fehler, wenn man dann die Geduld verliert, dann ist es braun, dann ist es im Arsch. Dann kam er nämlich auch hoch und sagt, ja, deine neue Installation. Ich so, wie neue Installation. Und man hätte halt einfach noch länger warten sollen. Einfach rausgehen, bald spazieren, irgendwas. Mal wieder alte Freunde besuchen, hätte alles geholfen. Aber naja.
Aber es geht. Also ich habe das jetzt nicht nochmal neu anzuwetten. Ich hatte seitdem keine Probleme.
Ja, ich bin terminiert.
Und es liegt eben nicht in deiner Gig-Leitung, von der du sowieso bloß eins hast. Weil du hast ja nicht mehr als einen Gig an einer Maschine dran. Ich habe zwischendurch, nachdem der auch mal so ein bisschen wartet, ich bin dann immer so ein, was macht die gestern? Und dann bin ich ja so ein Netzwerk-Freak. Weißt du, ich träume ja nachts in Wireshark. Und der macht da nichts dabei. Also das Netzwerk hilft dir nicht.
Ja, aber beim Runterladen hat es geholfen.
Ohren auf die Festplatte gelegt.
Ja, das geht nicht mehr. Der Zug ist echt abgefahren. Das finde ich total ätzend.
Toll war auch das Server-Update. Weil wenn du einen Server hast ohne Monitor, sprich über Screen-Sharing, da so remote dein Update draufspielst, dann kannst du den Server-Update nicht vorher runterladen, also nicht vorher updaten. Spielst du jetzt aber das neue, das Mavericks drauf, geht natürlich die alte Server-Variante nicht. Sprich, dein Screen-Sharing ist halt auch ausgeschaltet beim Hoffahren. Terminal, das dann wieder anschalten, hab ich dann gemacht. Also nicht die Server-Version, sondern die User-Version vom Screen-Sharing kannst du dann wieder so anschalten. Und dann, weil ich natürlich auch meinen DNS-Server drüber laufen habe, der dann auch nicht mehr ging, musste ich dann natürlich...
Ich glaube, das war eher der Problem. Ich hab ja auch diverse Headless-Max. Und davon hab ich jetzt auch inzwischen ein, zwei geupgradet. Das geht durchaus Headless. Also da brauchst du nichts an der Glotze. Aber wenn du natürlich das DNS ohne auf der Kiste drauf hast, und sie nur das benutzt selber, dann hast du natürlich ordentlich den Fuß geschossen. Aber grundsätzlich geht das Headless updaten.
Also dann lag's eher am DNS irgendwie.
Ja, das ist tödlich. Also wenn eine Kiste nur sich selber als DNS-Server hat und man da ein Update drauf macht, dann ist es irgendwie doppelt plus ungut.
Es ging dann irgendwann. Ich hab dann das mal wieder bei einem neuen DNS-Server gesetzt und irgendwann ging's dann auch ohne Demolitor hin und her zu tragen. Aber es war nicht schön, so richtig smooth war es nicht. Hätte ich doch gleich beides updaten können. Wenn ich dann schon so einen Server habe und dann auch bezahle dafür, dann soll ich mich doch fragen, soll ich gleich das mit updaten und dann die Services danach wieder hochfahren.
Ich hab ja noch für solche Sachen, nur als kleiner Tipp nochmal, ich hab für solche Sachen an der echten Hardware, ich hab ja sehr viel virtualisierte, da war ein echter Hardware, da hab ich noch sogenannte Spiders dran. Das sind so eine kleine Kästchen, Ethernet auf der einen Seite und VGA und USB auf der anderen Seite. Und damit kannst du sozusagen über einen Webbrowser, wie KVM, so ein Ding über IP. Für dieses Ding ja. Wobei man das aber glaube ich auch so ansteuern kann, weil dieses Java-Applet macht hinterher auch nichts anderes als dieses Remote-Fremdbuffer-Protokoll. Also vielleicht kann man das sich auch mal ersetzen, aber diese Dinger, die gab es mal so richtig massenhaft zu kaufen, gibt es auch immer noch auf Ebay oder so, haben dummerweise nur einen VGA-Adapter fest. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt den nächsten Mac Mini da mal wieder anschließe, muss ich mir überlegen, wie ich das mache, weil ich will jetzt nicht den einen Thunderbolt-Port dafür opfern, dass der einen VGA-Adapter dran bleibt. Dieses Spider gibt es leider nicht als HDMI.
Es gibt doch HDMI-VGA-Adapter bestimmt, oder?
Ja, das wäre jetzt so mein nächster Blick. Soweit gibt es natürlich noch mal in groß und für teuer, aber dann zahlst du halt eben eine dreifache für so ein KVM-System als für den eigentlichen Mini und das ist irgendwie auch blöd. Diese Lantronix Spider war mal eine relativ günstige Sache, die, wie gesagt, bis heute auch noch ganz gut halten. Die können auch noch so ein Spiel, das wollte ich nur sagen. Das finde ich sehr krass.
Das wollte ich nur sagen. Lass mich nochmal ausreden hier.
Das habe ich sogar schon mal benutzt. Die können so Schweinkram machen. Du kannst irgendwo, wenn du einen Fallzauber hast, kannst du ein Image hinlegen von irgendwas, zum Beispiel von so einem Mavericks Install-Ding, so einem virtuellen USB-Stick. Den mounted der dann per SMB, dieser Spider, und steckt den dann über seinen USB-Port in diesen Rechner rein. Das heißt, du hast sozusagen Remote-USB-Stick. Das ist besonders eklig, aber das kann dir echt den Arsch retten, weil einer meiner Minis steht in Kalifornien. Und da jetzt hinzufliegen, nur weil man Blutprobleme hat, dann mache ich lieber sowas. Und das funktioniert auch wirklich gut.
Okay, 260 Euro steht das hier drin.
Ja, hier in Euro kannst du aber auch woanders schießen oder gebraucht oder so.
Wer ist das Ding?
Lantronix Spider.
Spider-Man... Lantronix Spider KVM Over-IP?
Kann ich auch mal zeigen, wie so ein Login da aussieht. Also, es ist ganz lustig. Spricht, ich bin sogar schon vor sechs, schon ein bisschen älter, aber spricht vor sechs und ich finde lustige Authentication.
So, jetzt hat es mir hier kalt am Rücken, Freunde. Dennis, wollen wir mal Stühle tauschen? Na, wäre ein bisschen fair aber eigentlich.
Kannst meinen haben.
Hier gibt es einen noch gehabt. Wo ist der andere?
Ja, der hat ja alles schon rausgeschnitten. Deiner ist der letzte, der ist auch bald dran.
Tja, das ist ja das Glück von dem, der zuletzt kommt immer. Weil, ihr nehmt ja mal erst die anderen.
Na, das ist reine Solidarität deiner Bequemlichkeit gegenüber.
So, jetzt habe ich schon wieder vergessen, was ich...
Du wolltest die ganze Zeit etwas ganz Wichtiges sagen, oder?
Ja, ich dachte mal, er wäre fertig.
Jetzt bin ich fertig. End of file.
Es ging Mavericks waren wir gerade, ne?
Ich hatte auch noch so ein paar interessante Effekte. Also unter anderem habe ich ja diese iCloud Keychain mal in Betrieb genommen. Konnte mich dann noch nicht zurückhalten. Und abgesehen davon, dass die ja da allerlei lustige Doppel- und Dreifach-Absicherung und Zustimmungsattacken fahren mit irgendwie, ja, jetzt kriegst du noch eine SMS und bist du wirklich sicher und hier eine PIN und sowas. Was ich an sich aber ganz gut finde, dass ihr so was macht.
Ja, aber dass sie mich zwingen, was mein Passwort irgendwie, wie das sein soll, das nervt mich. Weil ich hab schon so eine gewisse Idee, wie mein Passwort auszusehen hat.
Ach so, dass sie jetzt so Regeln entforsten.
Ja, ja, also du legst so los. Ja, muss aber acht Buchstaben, also acht, Länge von acht haben. Ja, okay, Länge von acht. Und dann als nächstes irgendwie Großbuchstabe. Großbuchstabe, furchtbar. Ja, aber nicht drei gleiche hintereinander. Das geht mir gegen den Strich, weil das sorgt dafür, dass ich mir was komplett Neues einfallen lassen muss.
Was man sich vergisst.
Ja, und dann hast du es vergessen. Und dann kannst du es nicht resetten, weil dann fragt er dich nach deinen Sicherheitswörtern da. Ja, what the fuck, was weiß ich, was da für Sicherheitswörter eigentlich sind. Und das sogar bei einem Test-User, ein, wo du betesten willst. Das heißt, jedes Mal, wenn ich jetzt teste, weil ich will hier In-App-Purchase machen und so ein Shit, muss ich jetzt irgendwie so ein scheiß komisches langes Passwort eingeben. Ich will doch nur In-App...
Du brauchst ein Schema.
Hab ich ja. Die lassen mich mein Schema nicht benutzen.
Nein, du brauchst ein anderes Schema.
Ja, deren Schema. Ist doch scheiße.
Weil jeder auch nur ein anderes.
Weil mein geiles Passwort-Crack-Programm kann ich jetzt vorbereiten. So, es muss mindestens acht lang sein, mindestens ein Buchstabe groß, auf gar keinen Fall drei doppelt. Da fallen schon wieder 20 Prozent aller Passwörter weg. Muss ich weniger suchen.
Auf jeden Fall habe ich diese iCloud Keychain eingeschaltet. Und dann gab es ein paar lustige Effekte, die ich überhaupt nicht gerechnet hatte. Nämlich, wenn man mehrere Macs miteinander synkt. Und ich hatte an dem einen nahezu alle meine Twitter-Accounts in diese, wie heißt diese, PrefPane jetzt? Internet-Accounts heißen die jetzt. Genau, das haben sie jetzt endlich mal sinnvoll benannt. Internet-Accounts. Da hatte ich so meine ganzen Twitter-Accounts drin. Und aus irgendwelchen Gründen, die ich wirklich partout nicht verstanden habe, konnte ich hier an meinem Laptop einen meiner Twitter-Accounts da nicht konfigurieren. Weil er immer meinte, ich hätte das Passwort falsch eingegeben, aber ich habe definitiv das richtige Passwort eingegeben. Das hielt sich hier über Wochen. Und ich dachte, ich bin verrückt.
Tim, du bist verrückt.
Durch dieses Danke. Danke aus deinem Mund. Und durch dieses Syncing werden nämlich auch diese Twitter-Accounts gesynkt. Also er synkt halt mehr als nur Passwörter, sondern er synkt halt auch diese Accounts. Und auf einmal habe ich quasi von dem Rechner, wo ich den eintragen konnte, jetzt auch auf dem anderen Rechner diesen Twitter-Account. Das ist ein merkwürdiger Effekt.
Warum muss ich dann in diesem Internet-Accounts-System-Preferenz meinen Twitter-Account?
Musst du gar nicht. Aber wenn du das machst, dann können halt Programme darauf zugreifen, ohne dass du immer wieder jedes einzelne Programm authentifizieren musst.
Du kannst dann gleich von der Kamera- oder Bilder-App Twitteren, ohne irgendwie in die Twitter-App gehen zu müssen. Sondern die haben jetzt gleich dein Bild in.
Und deine NSA, die NSA kann auch mit.
Ja, und hier über Notification und Twitteren und tralala, das ist schon sinnvoll. Dann hast du auch die Notification. Ob du das haben willst, ist jetzt mal eine andere Frage. Ich hatte das halt drin, ich habe da jetzt auch nicht viel drüber nachgedacht in dem Moment. Mir fiel bloß auf, dass durch dieses Syncing ihm auf einmal das beizubringen war. Irgendwas ist da kaputt. Naja, und dann habe ich noch was anderes entdeckt. Und zwar habt ihr nicht auch immer dieses Problem mit, ich bin im Finder, ich starre auf einen Bildschirm, jetzt hätte ich gerne ein Terminal, was sich in diesem Ordner befindet.
Da gibt es da schon lange irgendwelche Tools.
Da gibt es schon lange irgendwelche Tools. Und man hat da immer irgendwie Open Terminal hier und irgendwelche komischen Apple Skripte, die dann bei jedem Update brechen. Und im App Store gibt es auch noch irgendein Tool, was das macht. Bis ich dann im Rahmen des Herumstocherns in den neuen Keyboard Shortcuts festgestellt habe, dass schon seit Lion, oder spittestens Mountain Lion, ich glaube sogar schon seit Lion, dass es ein Standard-Service ist im OS X, den man einfach nur einschalten und einer Funktionstaste zuordnen muss. Also dieses Open This Finder Window in Terminal gibt es standardmäßig.
Bei mir nicht.
Ich kann das euch ja hier mal kurz zeigen. Also du gehst in die System-Preferences in Keyboard, dort in die Shortcuts, also wo die ganzen Tastaturkürze geübt werden. Und da gibt es dann diesen Bereich Services, wo halt diese ganzen sinnlosen Dienste, die auch 1000 installierte Programme alle machen, was sie sehr konvertieren. Und dann gibt es eine Sektion darin, eine Sektion Files and Folders. Das ist ja alles nur auf Englisch. Und da steht New Terminal and Folder und New Terminal Tab and Folder. Und da kannst du dir dann eine Funktionstaste drauflegen, oder welchen Shotcut auch immer, und dann hast du diese Funktionalität. Out of the Box.
Ich glaube, das ist ja schon... Sonst zur Not nimmt man einfach vom Finder-Fenster oben das Eigen und lässt es in seinen Terminal feinden.
Ja, aber es ist halt... weiß ja, wie das ist. Man will ja irgendwie nicht mehr als eine Taste drücken. Gibt es bestimmt auch 1000 Tools, aber es geht halt auch komplett ohne Tools.
Führ mal vor. Aha, jetzt, jetzt kommt's. Es geht gar nicht.
Es funktionierte bei manchen Rechnern nicht auf Anhieb. Und ich hab nicht verstanden, warum.
Weil die Tastasche noch von was anderem belegt ist.
Nach dem Ausloggen, also hier geht's, ja.
Und wo bist du jetzt?
Ich hab mein Finder eben relauncht.
Na, ich war in diesem, in dieser Ab, die ich hier grade markiert habe.
Ach so, du bist sogar hier in diesem Overview-Dings. Mach mal PVD da.
Also, wenn ich jetzt hier nur das Fenster anklick und da nicht selektiert habe, äh, dann, äh, Moment.
Mach mal PVD. Man sieht ja gar nicht, wo du bist im Terminal. Ach, da vorne steht's ja, Satu-App. Geh mal nochmal bitte zwei Dinger zurück. Das ist genau das, was ich bei mir hab. Nee, nimm Feinder zweimal zurück. Oder erstmal einmal bitte. Und nochmal. Hey, jetzt ist es weg. Du hattest eben gerade so Unterteilungen, wo auch irgendwie Production und Zeug, wo du lauter so Unterteilungen hast. Und das hab ich bei mir zu Hause auch. Aber von Ordnern, die ich selber angelegt hab und ich seh die jetzt parallel und ich kann die nicht mehr so cool einzeln ansprechen wie vorher. Du hattest gerade so einen Zwischenview, der genau wie der buggt, außer den ich zu Hause habe. Und da war so eine Zwischenzeile so gräulich, wo Production da stand oder irgendwie so was Ähnliches. Ja, aber ich hab's bei dir gerade auch kurz gesehen. Wo der ganze Bildschirm voll war, bis unten hin, und der war so zwei oder drei geteilt. Wahrscheinlich ist es sogar ein Feature, aber es ist...
Achso, was du meinst, ist was anderes. Du meinst...
Ja, das, genau!
Ja, das ist die Sortierung nach Kategorien.
Ja, aber wo kommen denn die her? Pass auf, ich hab bei mir einen Movies unten in Serious-Orden angelegt, und die werden so angezeigt, und ich kann die nicht mehr einzeln auseinanderhalten.
Ja, Application-Kategorie heißt das. Im Finder ist das Arrange by Application-Kategorie. Jedes Programm ist irgendeiner solchen Kategorie zugeordnet, und das wahrscheinlich über App-Store-Geschichten oder...
Aber da sind doch... Ich hab das für Movies und so. Ich hab nicht... Also, wo kommt denn das her? Oder weil ich das halt Movies genannt hab und der denkt dann alles, klar, das ist eine App-Store-Kategorie, und jetzt bringt er meine Ordnerstruktur durcheinander.
Super. Das ist ja keine Ordnerstruktur, sondern...
Doch, bei mir schon.
Ich versteh nicht, was du meinst. Auf jeden Fall kannst du das hier umstellen und dann...
Ich werd das mal machen. Vielleicht hat sich das ja irgendwie ausversehend mal eingeschaltet.
Hat jetzt bestimmt keiner...
Column View Users im Klaren Vorteil. Das ist irgendwie so ein Generationsproblem wahrscheinlich, ne?
Nee, eigentlich sollten das ja die Älteren haben, weil das so ein Next Thing ist, weil...
Ich bin total der Column User.
Nee, mich nervt das. Da seh ich viel zu viel, was mich gar nicht interessiert.
Das geht mir bei diesem anderen View. Eher so, weil er immer irgendwelche Sachen ausgeklappt und ich gar nicht ausgeklappt haben will gerade.
Mit Ausklappen arbeite ich auch nicht. Ich bin reinwandern und zurückwandern. Ich wander da so durch, aber ich will nix ausgeklappt. Ich weiß, wie mein Baum aussieht.
Das ist das Beste, das ist der Outliner.
Was hast du mit deinem Outliner?
Naja, wusstest du, dass der Finder ein Outliner ist?
Ich will da eintauchen und will den Rest dann weghaben. Warum brauche ich dann eine Baumstruktur, wenn ich ja doch wieder alles anzeige? Dann kann ich gleich alles flach machen.
Wie kommt dir denn mit den Tabs so klar?
Die entstehen manchmal, wenn man halt so Command-Click macht und davon ausgeht, dass sich ein neues Fenster öffnet. Dann kommt dir jetzt auf einmal ein neues Tab. Das ist noch ein bisschen ungewohnt, aber hat den Vorteil, dass man leichter drehen und droppen kann.
Also ich brauchte noch nie Tabs im Finder.
Ich nutze Tabs nicht mehr im Browser. Ich probiere es immer wieder, aber es ist nicht fest drin. Ich mache für jeden Scheiß ein neues Fenster auf und mache es mit Apple Web wieder zu.
Also ich finde es sehr gut, wenn man sich daran gewöhnt, nur zwei Finder Windows mit jeweils Tabs zu haben, kann man echt seine Produktivitätssteigerung kreizen.
Du meinst so Midnight Commander Modus, so Direktory Opus-mäßig.
Amiga Herr.
Ich wusste, dass du das kennst.
Ich mache mir hier auch immer zwei Finder-Fenster auf und habe hier mit dem Divi die dann so schön nebeneinander.
Eine Platzwache, nur alles weiß. Jeder hat halt so seinen Weg.
Aber es liegt der Feinerlich bei mir auf dem eigenen Space.
Ich könnte jetzt noch ein bisschen über Frameworks reden, aber ich glaube, da warten wir lieber, bis Roddi wieder da ist. Ja, irgendjemand erwähnte mir gegen mir, gestern haben wir im Club darüber gesprochen, ne, Dennis? Über DSLite. Aber du warst gar nicht mitdiskutiert, oder?
Nee, du hast mit dem anderen da irgendwas diskutiert.
Um mit Steve zu reden, it's a big bag of hurt. Was willst du wissen?
Ja, was will ich wissen? Also mir war dieser Begriff schon ein paar Mal irgendwie über den Weg gelaufen, aber ich hatte keine konkrete Assoziation, worum es sich dabei eigentlich jetzt konkret handelt, aber es kann natürlich sein, dass wir schon mal darüber gesprochen haben, oder?
Wir hatten es mal im Zusammenhang mit IPv6 angesprochen, dass es halt eine der Möglichkeiten ist, wie Provider mit möglichst hohem Schmerz für die User den IPv4-Konnektivität in einem modernen NAT noch geben können. Das ist ja das größte Problem. Also was macht es? Was macht DSLite? Warte mal, wer macht es? Nur die Provider. Internetprovider, und zwar die Endprovider, die dem Kunden nach Hause seinen DSL, seinen Kabel, seinen Schießmicht totgeben.
Alle?
Nein. All die Leute, denen IPv4-Adressen zu teuer sind.
Also in Deutschland findet das nicht statt.
Kabelprovider zum Beispiel. Kabel Deutschland macht das jetzt sehr gerne. Und auch andere, habe ich gelesen, machen das sehr gerne. Also was macht das? Das sorgt dafür, dass der Kunde zwar IPv4-Konnektivität hat, aber mit total krankem NAT. Jetzt wirst du sagen, das hat doch jeder. Jeder hat doch irgendwie seine Fritzbox oder seinen Router. Und die NATtet halt. Das Problem bei DSLite ist, das NAT machst nicht mehr du, sondern das macht dein Provider für dich. Genau, mit einer großen, bösen Kiste CGN, Carrier Grade NAT. Die macht das für dich. Und das bedeutet, du hast keinen Einfluss mehr darauf, was und wie sie tut. Das heißt also, die berühmten Portfreigaben, die man wenigstens noch auf seinem eigenen Router hatte. Um sowas kannst du alles knicken, kannst alle in die Tonne treten.
Also ein normales DSL hat ja eine IP-Adresse, und wenn du da mehr Rechner dran hast...
Die Kunden nicht mehr. Genau. Pass auf, DSLite ist eine Transitionsstrategie von sozusagen, wie führen wir V6 ein? Oder gibt es ja noch ein paar hundert Leute, die noch V4 haben wollen, also werfen wir denen wie ein Knochen vor, dass die noch V4-Seiten ansurfen können. Wie machen sie das? Das ist ja auch der Grund, warum Provider das tun. Du brauchst für die einzelnen Kunden draußen keine V4-Adressen mehr. Das heißt, sie nehmen V6-Adressen, die a, kostenlos sind, und b, von denen sie viel zu viele haben, mehr als sie brauchen.
Jeder hat mehr als der Brauch.
Du gibst deinem Kunden halt V6, und wenn der Kunde halt eine V4-Adresse ansurft, dann tunnelt dein Router, der bei dir zu Hause steht, dieses V4-Paket aus einem privaten Netz, was du zu Hause hast, also so ein Rfc1918-Netz. Nein, der macht da nicht natt. Nö, der nimmt das so und schubst es sozusagen an seinen Provider, transportiert es über V6, über so einen Tunnel, also V4 über V6, nicht so wie andere Leute das heute machen, also V6 über V4, sondern macht V4 über V6. Ja, zu deinem Provider, aber der nattet das halt eben. Das heißt, wie gesagt, für den Benutzer hat es den Effekt, dass er nach wie vor Nattquatsch hat mit all den Sorgen, die da mit drinstecken, wenn man V4 nattmacht. Aber du hast selber keinen Einfluss mehr drauf. Du kannst selber keine Dienste mehr annehmen.
Soll ich dir sagen, wann ich das gut finde? Weil es so scheiße ist, dass vielleicht denn die anderen mal sagen, so spiegelheise Trallader, die Content haben, dass die sagen, unsere Kunden werden ja nicht mehr richtig erreicht, wir machen jetzt mal noch mehr schneller V6. Weil IPv4 ist so schlecht geworden durch diesen Scheiß, dass die Migration vielleicht mal flotter geht.
Deswegen trauen sie sich ja, das anzubieten, weil sie ja sagen, der User soll eh kein Content anbieten von zu Hause. Das wollen sie ja nicht.
Nee, nicht der User. Ich meine, der User, die halt Spiegel unsurfen. Angenommen, Spiegel hätte nur noch IPv4. Ja, geht schon, aber das ist ja scheiße, das ist wahrscheinlich ein bisschen langsamer.
Und das Spiegel überhaupt V6 hat?
Na ja, haben die das noch nicht. Ja, wenn mehr Leute DSLite benutzen und irgendwie die Experience scheiße ist, dann sagt Spiegel ja vielleicht auch mal, ja irgendwie IPv4 ist ja langsam nicht mehr so doll, wir machen mal IPv6. Aber für andere Sachen dann halt, weißt schon.
Ja, aber die Anbieter sehen jetzt irgendwie Spiegel online, sie sieht jetzt nicht jeden Kunden mehr hinter einer eigenen Adresse, sondern sie sieht halt alle Kabel Deutschlandkunden auf einmal hinter einem Batzen von Adressen.
Das ist der nächste Grund, warum die dann scheiße finden werden. Kommt der Druck vielleicht mal von einer anderen Stelle?
Kann sein, ja. Aber das Problem ist glaube ich eher ein politisches. Das Problem ist, dass die Carrier sagen, wieso, das ist natürlich ganz toll.
von daher nicht nötig haben, das irgendwo reinzuschreiben. Das heißt, es gibt sehr, sehr viele Leute, ich kriege ja häufig so Tweets von Leuten, die dann total entsetzt darüber sind, die sagen, ich habe mir das supergeile 100 Megabit über meinen Kabelanschluss. Boah, ist das geil! Und dann so, oh fuck, DSLite. Nur noch tra-la-la, sozusagen verstümmeltes Netz. Meistens sind das dann sogar noch Carrier, die bringen dir sogar noch dein V6 um. Also die machen das auch noch kaputt. Das heißt, du hast sozusagen überhaupt keine Chance zu Hause auch nur irgendeinen Dienst zu launchen. Das heißt, all diese Leute, die jetzt anfangen mit das Internet der Dinge, die jetzt ihre Leucht-LED-Lampen per iPhone steuern wollen oder so.
Also ich meine, der bietet eh keine Störlust an.
Nein, das ist ja das Problem. Die Provider schreiben nicht hin, dass es DSLite ist. Das ist das, was ich meine. Also sozusagen, die Kunden darauf reinfallen, sagen, oh billig, 100 Megabit, voll geil, und tra-la-la und stellen fest, dass sie, egal was sie zu Hause machen, sozusagen einstärzen. Ja, sie können doch Facebook anklicken und YouTube gucken. Das geht alles noch. Aber selber irgendwie was machen, zu Hause kannst du knicken. Du bist sozusagen voll da drin, in dem Sack, und das ärgert dich natürlich sehr. Und dann musst du natürlich wieder anfangen, jetzt wirklich mit VPNs und all möglichen anderen Methoden, dich da wieder mühsam rauszubohren oder sowas. Und das Problem ist, wie gesagt, dass die Provider alle mit den Schultern zogen. Du sagst doch voll normal, du kannst doch Facetube gucken. Ja, dann ist doch die Welt in Ordnung. Was kann man mehr wollen? Du bist ein Konsumer. Du hast hier fertigst keine Sachen von zu Hause anzubieten. Keine Podcasts, keine Mail-Server, kein Nix, kein gar nichts. Ja, also beschwer dich nicht. Solange du Facetube klicken kannst, Halsmaul.
Aber die Latenz von meinem Shooter ist so hoch durch diese Scheiß NAT.
Kann sein, ja. Je nachdem, wie Carrier Grade das ist, was die da einige oft haben. Aber das kann durchaus sein. Wobei jetzt deine Shooter, nur so nebenbei, also ich weiß ja, ich shoote ja immer dieses alte Zeug, aber dieses alte Word of Warcraft spricht V6 schon ziemlich lange.
Kann man reinstellen.
Und das wird nicht NATtet. Also wenn du so einen DSLite-Anschluss hast, kannst du abgehend V6 direkt raus machen und so. Ja, das geht. Deswegen beschweren sich halt viele Leute, weil sie sozusagen, weil die in untergeschoben wird. Weil sie sozusagen sich ein Internet bestellen, aber nur verkrüppelt das Internet kriegen sozusagen. Das ist eigentlich das Haupterren, das ist dabei.
Ich habe übrigens ja immer mit Kabel Deutschland telefoniert, mit Support. Ich habe ja noch so ein echtes V4.
So ein Altvertrag.
Classic. Aber auch mit 100 MBit. Und da meine ich dann auch so, weil der Fraps und so und so ein paar andere, die ja bei Kabel Deutschland auch schon mal tätig waren, also vielleicht so ein paar Insider-Tipps haben, was man da so konfigurieren kann in ihren Interfaces. Da habe ich dann mal angerufen und meinte so, ja wie geht es denn aus? Also ich habe jetzt hier so ein Altvertrag. Und sie könnten jetzt hier so theoretisch auch dieses V6 da einfach so dazuklicken, ohne mich auf dieses Carrier Grade V4 runter zu stufen.
Theoretisch ginge das.
Und dann haben wir da auch so zehn Minuten lang drüber gesprochen. Das ist ja so theoretisch, also ja, aber eigentlich dann halt doch nicht. Also er war schon, ich hatte ihn glaube ich schon kurz davor zu sagen, ja na gut, na gut, ich klicke mal.
Du musst das halt manuell machen, weil deren Provisionierungsprozeduren, das ist immer wie üblich, Prozeduren, Prozeduren. Ja, das versteht wieder kein Hotliner, wenn du so eine Konfidation drauf hast.
Ja, doch, wobei bei Kabel Deutschland war ich auch letztens im Test. Kann ich übrigens auch bestätigen, ich finde den Support bei denen ja schon eigentlich ziemlich geil.
Ja, aber die können bloß die Prozeduren.
Ja, klar, aber zumindest...
Das heißt, wenn du dann Kunden provisionierst, mit was was nicht vorgesehen ist, dann drehen die am Rat.
Zumindest kann man mit denen irgendwie auch so normal sprechen. Das ist irgendwie ein ganz anderes Support-Erlebnis als jetzt Telekom oder Alice oder...
Ich hab letztens bei 1&1 angerufen und nicht weil ich da Kunde bin, sondern weil meine E-Mail-Adresse dort seit etwa acht Jahren ge-spam-blogged ist, aus irgendeinem Grund. Wo meine Haupt-E-Mail-Adresse nicht mein Server oder sonst irgendwas weiß ich, was die da irgendwann mal gemacht haben.
Das 1&1 Call Center sitzt bei uns im Gebäude.
Und sie konnten und sie schreiben wirklich auf ihrer Webseite, dass man dann dort in der Hotline anrufen soll, wenn man so ein Problem hat.
Musstest du bezahlen, um von der Blacklist runterzukommen?
Nee, dass man da anrufen sollen, dass sie dann ein Abuse-Center haben. Die haben tatsächlich ein Abuse-Center. Ich hab dann angerufen und er konnte mich nicht weiterleiten, weil ich keine Kundennummer hatte. Er hat das Problem verstanden. Er sieht es auch dort in seiner Prozedurliste, dass das möglich ist. Aber er hat in seinem Interface keine Möglichkeit gehabt, dort irgendwo hinzuklicken.
Warum hattest du keine Kundennummer?
Weil ich keinen Kunde bin.
Du musst ihn mal anrufen lassen, der Mail von dir bekommt und der dort Kunde ist.
Gib doch einfach irgendeine Scheiß-Kundennummer. Willst du irgendeine Eins-eins-Kundennummer haben? Kap, welche? Ich verstehe irgendwie wieder nicht. Wenn ich so einen Scheiß schon baue für so eine Hotline, würde ich denen mit so einem Postzettel eine Pseudokundennummer an ihr Terminal kleben. Und sagen, pass mal auf, wenn du hier ein Problem hast, aber keine Kundennummer, tippst du die halt ein.
Ja, das machen die Profis, die damit schon ein bisschen länger sind.
Da gab es doch jetzt noch eine Nachfrage.
Sekunde mal, Tim.
Lass mich doch mal ausreden jetzt, Herr Tim.
Wie kommst du denn jetzt da drauf?
Wie komme ich wo drauf?
Du bist doch noch unberührt von DSLite.
Ja, dessen wollte ich mich gerade mal versichern. Und in der Diskussion gestern kam noch die Frage auf, was denn das bedeutet mit diesem Carrier Grade NAT. Also es ist nicht so, dass das jetzt irgendwie mein Heimnetz dasselbe Broadcast-Domain hat, dass da jetzt irgendwie alle Pakete...
Nee, du kriegst nur 192 Adressen oder so, hoffe ich. Wenigstens eine ordentliche in 1918, oder wie die heißen?
Du bist vor dem Prinzip auf der Außenseite deines Routers, kriegst du auch noch mal wieder eine private Adresse.
Außenseite meines Routers eine private Adresse?
Du kriegst doch jetzt gerade eine echte Adresse und dann kriegst du halt keine echte Adresse mehr.
Sozusagen ja, jein. Aber die liegt halt eben nicht bei dir, sondern die liegt bei dem Provider. Dein Router spricht mit dem CGN-Device bei deinem Provider V6. Das heißt, außerhalb deines auf der DSL-Leitung oder Kabel-Leitung, aber wie auch immer, ist von der Außenseite deines Routers bis zum CGN-Device nur V6.
Und da landen dann letztlich wirklich nur die Outbound-Pakete, die sowieso raus sollen und die gehen dann halt zu diesem CGN.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz, du hast keinen Einfluss auf das Tun und Arbeiten dieses CGNs. Du kannst auch Dynamic DNS nicht benutzen. Genau, jetzt kannst du alle in die Turnhalle treten.
Okay, das ist ja die damit verbundene Frage, wie schlimm ist denn das NAT dann letztlich? Weil im Prinzip, im Prinzip könnte das ja auch alles ganz gut sein, wenn da mal sozusagen ordentliches NAT gemacht wird, in Anführungsstrichen. Naja, aber wo zumindest diese Turnhalle-Protokolle jetzt nicht auch noch komplett versagen. Also dass zumindest die Techniken, die es gibt, um durch so ein NAT durchzustoßen, dann auch funktionieren und damit eben, in dem Moment, wo es an der Stelle für alle implementiert ist, auch für alle funktioniert und dann nicht immer dieses Dilemma ist, du hast noch irgendeinen Ho Chi Minh-Router, der das halt irgendwie nicht kann und du wirst ja in den nächsten drei Jahren nie los und so.
Du wirst wahrscheinlich immer irgendwelche Ports haben und die sind einfach immer alle belegt.
Ja, aber das Problem ist, dass es auch einfach Protokolle gibt, die kannst du nicht so einfach natten. Ich gebe dir mal ein simples Beispiel für die ganzen Leute, die dir nämlich anfangen, das ist zwar Quatsch in so einem DSLite-Szenario, aber nehme an, du würdest jetzt einen SIX-Tunnel klicken wollen. Für die Leute, die IPv6 gerne haben wollen mit eigenen Adressen und so weiter. Das ist halt SIX in 4. Also nimm einfach ein IPv6-Paket, mach noch ein V4er drum und gut. Das Problem ist jetzt, wenn du nicht der einzige Kunde bist bei deinem Provider, nehme an, du bist jetzt so ein Kabel-Deutschland-Kunde. Und SIX hat ja nicht beliebig viele Pops.
Aber SIX ist jetzt wirklich ein denkbar schlechtes Beispiel dafür.
Ist egal. Alle Protokolle, die nicht UDP- oder TCP-basiert sind. Alle Protokolle, die nicht, zum Beispiel GRE, GRE kannst du benutzen oder bestimmte Kryptosachen, IPSEC, ESP-Protokolle, wenn du nicht ein NAT-Paket drumrum machst, also extra, die du noch mal in UDP einpackst, damit du so NATen kannst. Aled, was keine Ports hat, kannst du darüber eigentlich nicht NATen. Du kannst es NATen, aber du hast keine Garantie, dass es funktioniert. Deswegen habe ich dieses Six Tunnel jetzt mal als Beispiel aufgerufen. Nehmen wir an, es gibt bei Kabel Deutschland, ich nehme jetzt mal nur Kabel Kübel Deutschland als Beispiel für sowas, das ist ja nur ein Provider, der nur mehr als fünf User hat. Nehmen wir an, es gibt jetzt noch einen, der auch denselben Six Pop benutzt in Düsseldorf oder sonst irgendwas. Dann hat diese CGN-Kiste schlicht und ergreifend keine Chance, wenn ein Paket kommt, ein V4-Paket, von diesem Six Pop zu entscheiden, welcher seiner inneren Kunden das jetzt war. Er kann es sozusagen nicht zurücknatten. Er kann es rausgehen natten, aber rein wissen nicht mehr, wohin es hingehört. Deswegen kannst du bestimmte Sachen darüber einfach nicht machen. Das geht einfach nicht. Selbst wenn das CGN-Ding noch so super schlau ist. Was lernen wir daraus? Don't do it!
Gibt es schon eine Liste mit dieser Tarife, sind DSLite und Finger vonlassen und so?
Kabel Deutschland macht das jetzt für alle neue Kunden.
Oder auch hier, was war das? Kabel Baden-Württemberg. Gerade die Kabel sind da weit vorne weg. Finger weg von den Kübel Deutschlands. Na ja, wenn ihr da schon Kunde bist, wie Huckel und Happy und so. Ich meine, für die haben sie ja noch IP-Adressen. Sie werden auch einen Teufel tun und dir die wegnehmen. Das Problem ist halt, du musst dir überlegen, sie haben einfach nicht mehr nur V4-Adressen.
Ja, dann haben sie halt den IPv6 und den X verschlafen.
Die sind teuer. Rat mal, was eine V4-Adresse kostet, wenn du sie jetzt kaufen wolltest am Markt. Und du bittest 12?
In welchen Größen kauft man die denn?
In so Netzgrößen, also ich bin mindestens 16. Also 160.000 Adressen oder so.
Ach so, so groß. Das kriegst du nicht für 12 Euro, aber...
Ne, eine Adresse davon.
Pro Adresse, wir reden immer sozusagen genauso, wie du auf deinen Bitcoins guckst.
Nein, ich wollte schon so sagen, 2 Euro.
2.
Pro Adresse.
Hast du eine Ahnung, was eine V4-Adresse kostet, wenn man sie kauft? Der würde jetzt eine, die sie eh schon haben. Aber wenn sie die jetzt kaufen müssten, wenn sie jetzt hingehen, wenn sie die am Markt kaufen müssen, weil es gibt ja, von den Registries gibt es ja keine mehr, also mussten sie jetzt hingehen, dass die von jemand anderem kaufen müssen. So eine Slash 16 mit 65.000 Adressen? Nee, eine Viertelmillion reicht nicht. Ja, je nachdem, wo und wo. Es gibt ja welche, die kann man so richtig transportieren quer über die Welt. Die sind teurer. Es gibt welche, die kannst du nur im europäischen Raum einsetzen. Da ist noch ein bisschen Administrativscheiße dran. Die sind wieder billiger. Aber so in dem Dreh, so 12, 15 Euro kann man dafür schon anlegen für so eine IP-Adresse.
Noch ein Hinweis für die Kübel Deutschland-Kunden, die jetzt schon angefangen haben zu heulen, nachdem sie unsere Ausführungen gehört haben, weil sie irgendwie Opfer einer solchen Maßnahme geworden sind. Es gibt da wohl im Kundencenter, wenn man da anruft und weint, einen Schalter, der umgelegt wird und dann hat man wieder V4, nur V4 und dann kann man sich seinen V6 ordentlich selber machen.
Es macht Sinn, wenn du dir überlegst, die Strategie, weil die haben halt 90 Prozent ihrer Kunden, die wollen bloß Facetube klicken. Die merken davon nichts. Und die paar Leute, die zu Hause halt irgendwie noch was machen wollen, was denn nicht geht oder sonst was, die lassen sie halt mal kurz an der Hotline heulen.
Ich verstehe nicht, warum sie nicht gleich bei Vertragsabschluss irgendwie so ein Häkchen machen. So willst du eine coole Adresse, dann kostet das einmalig. Egal wie lange du es nutzt, zahlst du 15 Euro extra. Würde ich doch sofort machen.
Noch weitere Informationsupdate hier. Dein komisches Kabelmodem, was dann ein W-Lan gemacht hat, wenn es V6 ist, macht dann kein W-Lan mehr. Warum auch immer. Eigentlich wollen sie diesen Button im Kundencenter irgendwie loswerden bei Kübel, aber wenn es genug Nachfrage gibt, dann...
Also ich habe auf jeden Fall... Ich habe wirklich eine goldene Zeit erscheinbar erwischt, weil ich habe auch... Erstens gab es damals, glaube ich, noch monatliches Kündigungsrecht. Dann gab es... Du konntest auch den W-Lan-Route sein lassen, das war halt alles optional.
Du hattest auch einen Bridge-Modus.
Ich habe so eine Cisco-Kiste, wo so eine schwarze kleine Cisco-Kiste...
Du konntest auch loswerden, diesen Bridge-Modus.
Ja, aber ich habe irgendwie noch den ganzen coolen Scheiß eigentlich. Und die Einrichtung war ja auch ganz cool, da hatte ich ja am Freitag, wie gesagt, bestellt. Dann kamen die am Montag an, haben gesehen, oh, da ist noch ein alter Verteiler im Keller, kam am nächsten Tag wieder. Also wirklich, das war so zack, zack, zack, so vom DSL, die Telekom-Dramen, wenn der Techniker kam, aber gar nicht kam und so. Da war das so, ja, zack, irgendwie morgen, nächster neuer Verteiler, irgendwie schnell in den Keller geschraubt, irgendwie Messungen gemacht, Modem synchronisiert, Peng, IP und es war so, ah, ja, genau so, bitte. Wenn ich immer so höre von Kollegen, die sich jetzt gerade so frisch DSL klicken und die kommen halt von der ganzen Welt und haben ja so dieses Klischee im Kopf, so Deutschland, alles ordentlich, alles pünktlich und so weiter. Und dann warten die da zu Hause und der Telekom-Techniker soll zwischen 8 und 12 kommen. Er kommt nicht, sie rufen an und sagen, er hatte das Haus nicht gefunden. War da, ist keiner gekommen. In der Zeit sind irgendwie zwei Freunde bei mir durch die Tür rein und rausgekommen. Die haben geklingelt, es hat alles funktioniert, der Postbote war da, es hat keinen Scheiß. Und die verstehen das nicht mehr. Die ist irgendwie die Welt upside down.
Die beste Ausrede, die ich mal hatte, war, dass der Typ gesagt hat, er hat das Haus nicht gefunden. Und dann muss er, er hat ja seinen eigenen Verteiler von seiner eigenen Firma unten im Keller, mit seiner eigenen Nummer und den eigenen Lageplänen und weiß ich nicht alles, aber er hat das verdammte Haus nicht gefunden. Das liegt aber da. Genau.
Ja, die haben ihre Drittfirmen ja nicht im Griff, die verdienen sich da wie eine Nase.
Die machen das schon strategisch. Gerade wenn du DSL bestellst bei Drittfirmen, also nicht bei der Telekom selber, kriegst du natürlich nicht das höchst qualifizierte Personal für den Job. Und auch nicht das Personal mit dem geringsten Krankenstand. Da wird schon aufgepasst. Die Strategie, das ist halt bitter. Ich meine, auf der anderen Seite in Deutschland muss man dazu sagen, man kann jetzt auch mal eine Lanze brechen. Ich werde ja mal dafür schulden, dass die Telekom haue oder so. Wenn sie es erst mal hinbekommen haben, administrativ, dann ist halt die Stabilitätsrate von dem, was da ist, vergleichsweise hoch. Auch was ich so kenne aus dem Ausland oder so. Da kommt dann zwar ein Amiland der DSL-Techniker sofort morgen, aber der schraubt auch fünfmal rum und dafür fällt der Ding fünfmal im Monat aus. Und das muss man dann auch sagen. Okay, da bin ich eigentlich ganz zufrieden in Deutschland.
Also selbst im Wald. Ich wohne jetzt im Wald und habe jetzt auch noch ein anderes Haus noch weiter draußen wirklich im Wald.
Wie kannst du das leisten als VFX-Artist?
Werbebranche hat darauf gesagt, wir können nur da wohnen.
Ich kann nur im Wald wohnen. Und in dem einen, also im jetzigen Haus, wie gesagt, Miete auch ganz günstig, da ist halt wirklich eine Beleitung, die ist bestimmt 60 Jahre alt oder so. Das läuft halt stabil. Ich hatte da kurz mal zwischendurch, aber das lag nicht an der Leitung, die wirklich zum Haus geht, sondern wirklich eher vorne. Wenn es geregnet hat, wurde es ein bisschen langsamer. Das haben sie mittlerweile irgendwie hingekriegt, aber die Leitung da im Haus, die ist halt seit Jahren stabil, und jeden Tag habe ich da Internet, nicht einen ausfallen die ganzen Jahre. Und das andere ist wirklich auf dem Dorf. Und da haben die jetzt echt einen mit hingelegt, mit einem Wald.
Hab ich ja auch auf meinem Landsitz. Ich habe das schon mal erzählt, von 0 auf 16 Megabit, das war ja total Kulturschock für das Dorf. Ich hoffe, dass ich auch bald mal wieder einen Kulturschock entdehne. Das Beste waren die Gesichter, wenn sie mich so angucken. Wie komme ich jetzt ins Internet? Gar nicht, du bist schon drin. Ja, aber wie wähle ich mich denn da ein? Gar nicht, du bist schon drin. Okay, und wenn ich fertig bin, wie gehe ich wieder? Nein. Das Internet ist ja ausländisch, deswegen darf der BND das ja abhören. Habt ihr nicht gelesen, dass gerade der heiße Scheiß ist, die Ausrede, warum BND das ganze Internet abhören kann, weil das Internet ist ja ausländisch. Ist ja inherent ausländisch, deswegen darf man das alles abhören.
Das ist neuländisch.
Darf ich noch mal ganz kurz, nur weil es hier in dem Workflow steht, aber nur, wenn Huckel nicht beleidigt ist. Es gibt noch etwas, das ist noch fast ein bisschen schlimmer als DSLite, deswegen will ich dir jetzt nur kurz noch anführen, so in 60 Sekunden, um den Leuten, die DSLite haben, ein bisschen Zeit läuft. Zu sagen, dass sie noch nicht ganz am unteren Ende der Foodshale angekommen sind. Es gibt nämlich noch eine andere fiese Technik, die nennt sich NAT64 in Verbindung mit DNS64. Das macht folgendes, du hast sozusagen nur noch V6 zu Hause, gnadenlos, und all deine Apps, deine Browser und die Wellprogramme, und sie können das ja eh schon lange, und die machen denn folgendes, dass wenn du jetzt eine Seite abrufst, oder den Namen einer Seite per DNS abrufst, oder Seite, oder Site, oder wie auch immer, die nur eine V4-Adresse hat, dann lügt der DNS-Server deines Providers die in eine V6-Adresse um.
Aber die ist dann von einem Proxy?
Die ist dann von einem Proxy, bei Proxy gehen sie Füßchen, das Ding nennt sich After. Bei deinem Provider. Dein Gerät denkt, die ganze Welt würde nur noch aus V6 bestehen und spricht auch nur V6. Und das, was in der großen bösen Internet noch nicht V6 ist, wird einfach vom DNS umgelogen auf V6-Adressen.
Ich bin echt mal gespannt, wann wir nur noch V6 machen und IFP V4 einfach nicht mehr interessiert. Ich habe das Gefühl, bei dieser ganzen Scheiße, dass es dann doch relativ schnell geht, wenn es erstmal da ist.
Die ganzen Ausreden haben sie nicht mehr.
Ich habe auch so langsam diesen Eindruck, dass es alles sehr viel schneller gehen kann.
Bis es kommt, kann noch lange dauern. Aber wenn es dann da ist, glaube ich, ist das Alte ganz schnell weg.
Zumindest sind diese 80 Prozent relativ schnell.
Es wird dann spannend, wenn die richtig großen umschalten. Also so ein T-Mobile mit keine Ahnung, wie viele Millionen Smartphones haben die im Netz, 20 Millionen oder so. Wenn so ein T-Mobile mal von einem Tag auf den anderen sagt, okay, wir machen das mal an, dann springen ja die ganzen iPhones und die Androids springen sofort drauf. Die nehmen das sofort. Und schon hast du von einem Tag auf den nächsten 20 Millionen V6-Grundler mehr im Netz.
Da haben die Franzosen ja einmal gemacht, so ein Provider hat ja mal IPv6 eingeschaltet, so ein größerer. Dann hat es gleich in der IPv6-Grafik so gemacht.
Deutsche Telekom USA macht das.
Deutsche Telekom USA.
T-Mobile USA macht das.
Das Internet ist ja auch amerikanisch.
Nein, ausländisch. Die Amis erzählen ja das Gleiche.
Ja, das stimmt. Das ist für alle ausländisch.
Das Internet ist ausländisch.
Das ist nämlich vom Mond eigentlich.
Aber in Deutschland sagen sie, es wäre amerikanisch.
Der gute alte Sponti-Spruch, jeder ist Ausländer.
Irgendwo.
Jeder ist Ausländer, überall anscheinend.
Im Internet sind wir alle Ausländer.
Jetsa, mit kein Kurs. 327. Ist innerhalb dieser Sendung bisher schon um 10 Euro oder sowas wieder? Dennis, deine letzte Sendung heute, bevor du auswanderst, auf die INSY.
Gestern Abend Schlafe gegangen, als ich heute Morgen aufgewacht bin, waren es 303 oder so.
Also, ich habe bei 419 Dollar, weil die Profis reden nur über den Dollarpreis, bei der Sendung, also auf Arbeit war es 411 Dollar, hier waren es 419 Dollar, jetzt sind wir bei 440 Dollar. Also die Kurve, von der ihr ja vorhin noch, also zumindest Dennis meint, die ist ja noch relativ flach und so, kannst du mir näher erzählen.
50% Steigung pro Tag, crash die Scheiße. Da ist noch nichts gecrashed, 10% ist doch nix.
Ich verkaufe noch mal eine Coin. Das geht ja nicht.
Ja, ein halbes iPad hier. Weil so eine Feiglige, alle immer so ein bisschen verkauft, nicht crash das auch nicht, weil das ja dafür sorgt, dass es langsamer steigt.
Tim, verkaufe doch zwei und verkaufe dir das iPad Retina Mini mit Soße und Schaf.
Da müsst ihr aber drei verkaufen. Das hat getroffen. Weil es gibt Leute, so wie du, also die Gewinnmitnehmer gerade, die verkaufen ja. Und wenn die verkaufen, heißt das, dass die Blase immer ganz minimal Luft ablässt. Das ist ja, wenn du verkaufst. Und dadurch steigt es aber auch nicht so krass. Und gleichzeitig, weil es aber lauter so Mini-Verkäufe sind, kommen auch keine Panikverkäufe. Das heißt, es geht weder krass nach oben, noch krass nach unten. Eigentlich ist es ganz gut, dass es lauter kleine Mini-Deals gibt.
Na einer müsste halt mal so 10.000 Bitcoins wieder auf einen schlagen.
Ja, das passiert, wenn es krass nach oben geht. Weil dann wissen die, dass es bald fällt.
Und dann machen alle Panikverkäufe. Es geht krass nach oben.
Dann weißt du nicht mehr, wie das krass... Wann war das? Im März oder April? Da ging es nicht 10% am Tag hoch. Da ging es an einem Tag um die Hälfte hoch. Ich weiß, dass Jay Garzik im Februar einen Avalon-Miner bekommen hat. Als allererster von allen haben sie ihm den ersten Protobasic geschickt. Was er allein mit dem Ding gemeint hat, das hatte irgendwie 80 Giga-Hash im Februar. Das kannst du ja mal ausrechnen, was der da hat seitdem. Der hat immer mal erzählt, der hat sein Haus renoviert.
Aber guck dir das jetzt mal an, es steigt von einem anderen Niveau, aber das ist schon...
Aber Huckel, wie viel Prozent sind es heute gestiegen? Nicht mal zehn.
Los, Tim. Drei Bitcoins und dann hast du deinen...
Der Markt ist ja nicht viel größer gewachsen.
Das ist doch egal, da kauft einer Bitcoins gerade.
Hallo, warum, verdammt nochmal, gibt es dann für diesen Scheißdreck keine ordentliche Software? Ich quäle mich hier immer noch mit so einem völlig proletarischen Bitcoin-QT-Kleintrum.
Machst du das auch, nimm nur den anderen.
Ach, welchen anderen denn?
Command Line. Da kannst du dann so Features machen wie Send To Many, da kannst du nämlich mit einer Transaction an mehrere Leute senden, das geht da gar nicht. Und damit schonest du nämlich die Blockchain, das ist wichtig.
Wie Send To Many, ich kann ein Euro an mehreren Stellen ausgeben?
Du kannst in einer Transaction gleich mehrere Sachen reinpacken.
Mehrere Sachen, was?
Du kannst sagen, bitte dem so viel Coins und dem so viel Coins und das kommt in eine Transaction. Wenn du das da machst, dann entstehen da zwei Transaction. Und jede Transaction kostet in der Blockchain halt Platz und so weiter und so fort.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, wem ich hier irgendwelche Coins schicken soll.
Ich leg mir sogar eine Rollett an dafür.
Was ist denn die Dienstleistung dafür?
Dass wir hier in deinem Podcast teilnehmen und hier deine iPad-Minis finanzieren.
Und wer hat die Pizza bezahlt?
Ja, auf jeden Fall ist das Dreck. Also ich verstehe es nicht. Irgendwie jedes dritte Mal, wenn ich dieses Ding starte, muss er irgendwie alle seine Blöcke reindizieren.
Was? Jedes dritte Mal echt? Ich will das auch. Jedes Mal muss das scheiß Ding das machen. Nein, du fängst gerade von vorn an oder was?
Weil es scheiß Dreck ist.
Also die Blockchain, die liegt in Home Library Application Support Bitcoin. Da liegt die. Da liegt übrigens auch deine Wallet. Also alle Hacker, wenn ihr immer von Max die Wallet klauen wollt, da liegt die. Aber das wissen die Hacker ja alles. Und warum du da immer von… Ja, genau. Die wissen das nämlich nicht. Weiß nicht, warum der bei deiner Blockchain immer von vorn anfängt.
Aber du kannst ja diesen anderen Kleint, es gibt einen anderen GUI-Kleint auch. Der ist aber auch nicht hübscher, aber der geht ein bisschen sportlicher mit dieser Blockchain um.
Bisschen sportlicher.
Ja, wie heißt denn der? Warte mal, ich muss nochmal kurz gucken. Auf Bitcoin Org wird der verlinkt.
Welche Version hast du denn überhaupt, Tim? 0.8.5. Alles darunter sollst du nicht nutzen.
Noch schlimmer.
Wahrscheinlich hast du nie zu Ende rechnen lassen.
Da siehst du mal, jetzt mal hier eine Bitcoin verkaufen geht nicht.
Klar.
Ne?
Multi-Bit. Multi-Bit.
Du kannst halt nicht überprüfen. Wenn dir einer Bitcoin schickst, dann kommt die halt jetzt noch nicht an, weil dafür musst du eine Blockchain-Update nochmal schicken. Kannst du schon.
Im Chat, Tim, jetzt hier, Multi-Bit ist der andere Client, der von Bitcoin Org empfohlen wird. Ja, ist halt auch QT wahrscheinlich. Aber ist halt viel sch...
Ja, ich verstehe auch nicht, warum die sich nicht mal um eine ordentliche Lipp kümmern und das mit dem Goi andere machen lassen. Nein, einfach Lipp.
Vielleicht mit 3D grafen?
Einfach mal ein Mac Client. Ich meine, die Leute geben wenigstens Geld aus.
Mein toller Chat-Client hat mich disconnected. Magst du den Link nochmal posten?
Bitte?
Ah, multibit.org.
multibit.org.
Ja, aber da musst du auch die Blockchain runterladen, oder?
Ja, aber die laden da...
Schneller runter.
ich weiß gerade nicht mehr genau, wie sie es machen.
Willst du einfach meine Blockchain haben?
Ja, genau, ich glaube, sie laden halt.
Ich möchte deine Wallet haben.
Kann er haben, die ist eh Passportgeschützt.
Sie sagen halt, es dauert Minutes, um damit zu arbeiten und nicht irgendwie Stunden, weil wahrscheinlich laden sie sich einfach Blockchain-Snapshots irgendwo von vorn fahren.
Weil die wahrscheinlich die... Lib, BitcoinJ benutzen. Es gibt nämlich eine Lib, aber die ist halt in Java.
Ja, das ist der Grund, genau. Aber das kann man auch mit Ruby rappen und mit anderen Sachen. Das benutzen die ganzen Leute, die so ein bisschen mehr Computation-Power und so Concurrency-Features und so brauchen und aber gerne trotzdem Ruby schreiben. Und da rappst du halt diesen ganzen Java-Dödel-Syntax sehr elegant tatsächlich weg. Also, die haben sich richtig Mühe gegeben. Ist wirklich jetzt nicht so eine Krücke, sondern das benutzen Leute tatsächlich produktiv. Und dann kannst du halt eben so eine Concurrent-Hashmap aus irgendeiner Java-Library benutzen, wenn du sie halt brauchst. Und du musst dich nicht mehr um Threads und Threadpools selber kümmern, sondern kannst da das Dorf benutzen und das ist relativ stabil jetzt so seit zwei Jahren oder so und wird auch fleißig weiterentwickelt. Also DayRuby ist tatsächlich eine von diesen Alternativimplementierungen, die richtig sinnvoll sind oder performen.
Sagen wir mal, dieses Multi-Bit, nimmt das dieselbe Wallet-Show-Tour und so weiter wie?
Ich kann es dir nicht versprechen, ich habe es erst kürzlich gesehen, als mein Client mein 22-Wochen-Blockchain aufholen musste und ich mal geguckt habe, ob es eigentlich schon was...
22 Wochen?
Aber es ging. Zwei Tage hat es gedauert.
Zwei Tage mein Gott.
Das macht die Sache auch echt so.
Achso und in Mavericks, man muss dann hier das App-Nap ausschalten, sonst im Hintergrund hört er auf.
Ja, ich habe... Es ging alles super.
Was muss ich ausschalten?
App-Nap. Und wenn die Bitcoin-App nicht im Vordergrund ist, dann hört er einfach auf.
Ja, okay, mir ist bisher noch keine Anwendung eingefallen.
Ja, doch die.
Während Tim seine Blockchain updated und alle anderen gerade frische Bitcoins kaufen, würde ich ja mal ganz kurz hier auf ein kleines Kulturhinweis loswerden wollen. Zwar der Festsaal Kreuzberg. Jeder, der in Berlin haust und schon mal ausgegangen ist, wird vielleicht schon mal im Festsaal Kreuzberg gewesen sein für ein Konzert, eine Hochzeit oder einen Boxkampf. Das war auf jeden Fall eine sehr sympathische Location. Tansen. Genau, nahe des Cottbuser Tors. Die ist ja ausgebrannt vor ein paar Monaten. Da gibt es schon seit einigen Tagen so ein Start-Next-Projekt, Crowdfunding, um den halt wieder aufzubauen und zu renovieren. Die haben jetzt schon irgendwie festgestellt, dass sie ihn nicht abreißen müssen. Also der Brand war irgendwie nicht so schlimm, dass das Ding komplett Schrott ist. Die Grundmauer und alles könnte stehen bleiben, die Decke auch. Und jetzt, um hier so die Planung für den Wiederaufbau zu machen, brauchen sie noch ein bisschen Geld. Die haben jetzt schon 18.824 Euro und brauchen irgendwie 20.000 für die Fundingschwelle. Und das Funding-Ziel ist 30.000. Also jeder, der mal irgendwie noch so einen kleinen sympathischen Beitrag leisten will, kann da mal hier irgendwie so 20 Euro in die Kasse werfen. Oder 25.000 kriegt noch ein hübsches T-Shirt. Die habe ich auch schon gesehen. Die sehen wirklich ganz gut aus. Einfach mal reinwerfen, damit hier noch so ein bisschen alternatives Kulturprogramm erhalten bleibt und nicht irgendwie auf dem Gelände eine Penthouse-Loft entsteht. McDonalds oder sowas, ja. So, ich packe den Link mal da rein. Und alle, die cool sind und Mobile Freak Show hören, die geben da zumindest mal hier... Mobile Freak Show, irgendwie ein paar Euro dazu. Kulturprogramm.
Wenn wir beim Kulturprogramm schon bleiben, da gibt es bald noch so ein Kongress. Und der hat so Geburtstag, den 30. Dazu bräuchten wir noch so ein Material aus den vergangenen 30 Jahren, gerade so aus den ersten 15 Jahren, Video und Grafik, schickes, Headlines, whatever euch so einfällt.
Genau, da soll so ein bisschen was gemacht werden, vor allem für den Anfang. Und es ist ja auf CCC-Servern auch so einiges schon vertreten und auch auf Chaos Radio etc. Nur wirklich jetzt in all diesen ganzen Wirrwarr von Videos und Material auch wirklich interessante Stellen zu finden, das ist immer besonders schwierig. Also es gibt so diverse Tagesschau-Reportage, aber man weiß dann immer nicht so richtig, in welcher ist jetzt irgendwie kurz mal der Kongress zu sehen. Und wenn ihr sowas kennt und Videomaterial oder auch sehr gutes Foto-Material, das ist sicherlich genauso hilfreich.
Auf Flyer oder sowas.
Besonders gefragt ist Material noch aus Hamburg. Also Eidlstädter Bürgerhaus damals, die alten Zeiten, wo ich noch gar nichts gesehen habe. Das war dieser eine Kongress, der mal in Berlin war.
Da durfte man ja nicht filmen und keine Fotos machen.
Ja, schon. Aber es gibt halt was. Also es gibt Material. Die Frage ist nur, finden haben.
Weil Pöks auch mal schlafen musste.
Don't get me started.
Du bist ja aus dem Konzept, Mann. Also es gab ja mal ein Kongress, der tatsächlich in Berlin stattfand. Und zwar war das 1994, glaube ich.
Na, Art und Komm in der Budapester?
Genau. Also im Westen, das war Location-mäßig keine gute Idee, den Kongress da hinzubringen.
Der war ein bisschen komisch verteilt, Sportwerk-mäßig.
Ja, das hat nicht funktioniert. Das war nicht die richtige Location. Deswegen gab es ja dann auch diverse Bedenken, nochmal es in Berlin zu probieren. Aber der zweite Anlauf hat ja dann ganz gut funktioniert. Filmmaterial auch aus dem Haus am Kölnischen Park ist auch nicht üppig vorhanden. Und von daher, gerne gesehen, das Haus am Kölnischen Park, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es mitbekommen habt.
Ist weg.
Ist es schon weg?
Weiß ich nicht, aber du hast gesagt, aber es wird abgerissen. Wir haben uns wohl runtergerockt.
Die Nachbeben.
Wir haben jetzt nochmal nachgeschaut und es war nichts völlig.
Art Event hat dann den Rest gegeben.
Also ich weiß gar nicht, was jetzt die konkrete Geschichte war und was sie da jetzt planen, aber da war wohl mal irgendwelche Lofts geplant, aber ob das dann jetzt auch stattfindet, weiß ich nicht.
Wieder ein Kongress-Ding, oder?
Nein, das nicht.
Na dann, eine teure Wohnung.
Ja, das ist wohl eher so was. Also früher gehörte das ja mal der AOK, aber der gehört jetzt wohl nicht mehr.
Ja, haben sie verhölkert, ja.
Ja, dann so BCC-Zeit, das ist alles kein Problem. Da gibt es wirklich mehr als genug Material, aber diese ganzen alten Sachen, also Eidelschütter Bürgerhaus, der Bikinihaus-Kongress und natürlich das Eidelschütter Bürgerhaus.
Nee, also was auch immer da zu euch einfällt.
Genau, und ansonsten sollte irgendjemand von euch noch über nachdenken, ob er zum 30C3 fährt. Oder sie.
Was, ich oder was?
Ja, oder sie. Oder auch es.
Es ist auch für Mädchen.
Ich dachte nicht, ah, sollen alle kommen. Hast du vorhin den?
Was? Was pfeift denn hier so?
Was denn?
Mein Bitcoin-Rechner.
Vorhin habe ich das Wort Mädchen erwähnt.
Und?
Ja, hast du den Chat nicht gesehen?
Gab es gleich Shitstorm?
Hm, wenn du das Shitstorm nennst, hast du noch nie ein Shitstorm erlebt.
Lass uns das nicht vertiefen, das ist auf jeden Fall alles gerne gesehen. Und ich glaube, das wird cool.
Ja, wird sehr geil.
Also ich glaube, das wird sehr cool. Und wer letztes Jahr noch nicht da war, wird bestimmt einiges davon gehört haben, wie es war. Und das war schon ganz schön cool. Und ich glaube, diesmal wird es noch cooler. Also fetter wird es auf jeden Fall. Das bleibt nicht aus.
Es wird gefragt, wann es Karten gibt, sehr bald. Aber ihr braucht keine Angst haben, weil es gibt genug Karten.
Ja, man kann auch noch einen Tag vorher sich entscheiden, da hinzufahren, mit dem Handtuch über die Schulter kommt ja auch rein.
Die bauen ja da ein eigenes Rohrpostsystem. Ich glaube, da wurden auch schon ein paar Blickbilder gepostet. Wir haben das letztens getestet über mehrere Stockwerke und das funktioniert super gut. Ich war dabei. Durfte das Rohr halten, ganz oben.
Durfte das Rohr halten? Mensch Dennis, aus dir wird nochmal Wasser. Ein Rohrhalter.
Ja, ein ganz tolles Rahmenprogramm wird es auch geben.
Ich glaube, es wird sich auch sehr bemüht, dass der Party-Aspekt sehr zur Geltung kommt.
So, ich glaube, wir sind durch, oder?
Ja.
Ja, das war jetzt auch ausführlich.
Gar keine Mini-Themen heute.
Ja, wir hatten jetzt so große, große Themen. Da sparen wir uns mal ein paar kleine Mini-Themen. Oder hast du noch etwas ganz Wichtiges? Siehst du mal.
Du wolltest über diese Boxter reden, aber gut.
Machen wir das nächste Mal. Ich kann das jetzt nicht mehr.
Wir sind jetzt doch ganz schnell rum am Ende.
Ja, dabei war die Sendung sehr lang. Ja, Falk, vielen Dank.
Merci, was ihr gemacht habt.
Und ihr da draußen, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Für eure fortwährende Unterstützung. Sowohl die geistig-moralische, als auch die finanzielle. Und wir sehen und hören uns wieder in zwei Wochen. Irgendwie. Und dann sind wir alle wieder vereint.
Ja, gerade wo du es sagst, finanzielle Unterstützung, wir haben ja alle unsere Bitcoin-Adressen da. Auf der Teamseite. Aber es ist so außer... Also Flatter ist schon mal ganz gut.
Ist halt nicht die Konjunktur, so Bitcoin-Spenden bei so einem volatilen Ding, was irgendwie morgen gleich 1000 Euro Mehrwert ist.
Können die ja gleich mit einberechnen.
Das ist aber diese deflationäre Währung das große Problem, dass den Leuten natürlich das Geld nicht ausgeben.
Und die Fader langsam runterziehen werden.
Du kannst auch deine Musik schon blenden.
Ich blende erstmal die Musik mal ein bisschen ein, dann kommen wir jetzt hier auch irgendwie auf die richtige...
Bitcoinwellenlänge uns eintunen.
Genau.
Und das war's. Tschüss und bis bald.